fraktion spricht als erster steffen
bilger deutschland muss schneller werden
die sich stellenden herausforderungen
sind enorm
der nachhaltige umbau hin zur
klimaneutralität die digitalisierung die
sorge um die leistungskraft unserer
volkswirtschaft und der erhalt der
versorgungssicherheit wir brauchen
umfassende investitionen und zwar nicht
irgendwann sondern jetzt meine damen und
herren ich
finde es steht uns als union gut an
diesen antrag hier zur debatte zu
bringen wir erkennen an dass sich in der
koalition etwas tut bei der planungs
beschleunigung aber eben immer noch zu
wenig daher legen wir weitergehende
vorschläge auf den tisch
und es stehen uns auch gut an diesen
antrag einzubringen mit blick auf unsere
zurückliegende regierungsverantwortung
da haben wir einiges erreicht aber
die widerstände gerade des spd geführten
bundesumweltministeriums bei allem was
planen beschleunigt sind mir noch in
leidvollen erinnerung will nun mal
beispiele nennen das heißt die
modernisierung des bau- und
emissionsschutz rechts für den umbau der
landwirtschaftlichen nutztierhaltung hin
zu mehr tierwohl oder die für die
erreichen der klimaziele im verkehr
dringend zu beschleunigen
elektrifizierung auf der schiene auch
auf langen strecken all das war mit der
spd nicht möglich und auch von den
grünen gab es immer wieder kritik und
ablehnung wenn ich beispielsweise an
dass maßnahmen gesetzt zur legal planung
wichtiger infrastrukturprojekte denke
aber nun bestehen neue herausforderungen
und damit auch neue chancen
das thema planungs beschleunigung bei
allen demokratischen kräften nur wenn
bund länder und kommunen an einem strang
ziehen kommen wir wirklich voran aber
der entscheidende impuls muss vom bund
und von der bundesregierung ausgehen und
was macht die ampel die ampel verbot
unnötig zeit mit dem streit darüber was
gute und damit zu beschleunigende
infrastruktur und was weniger gute
infrastruktur ist und dass meine damen
und herren ist für mich absolut
unverständlich
wer es mit der transformation unserer
industrie ernst meint der muss
umfassende investitionen in
industrieanlagen rasch zum beispiel bei
der wasserstoffwirtschaft moderne
verkehrswege und zwar egal ob schiene
wasserstraße oder straße sind die
lebensadern vitale wirtschaftsstandorte
ohne sie leidet auch die soziale
teilhabe in stadt und land und wir
müssen auch auf vermehrte starkregen
ereignisse hochwasser oder dürreperioden
reagieren zügige verbesserung beim
hochwasserschutz wenn brauchbar deichbau
oder im bereich der wassernetze sind
zwingend die bundesregierung handelt
bislang dorf eng begrenzten feldern in
den genannten wo den etlichen anderen
bereichen braucht deutschland aber
ebenfalls ein beschleunigungs tober
meine damen und herren unser antrag ist
auch ein angebot des konstruktiven
miteinanders lassen sie uns gemeinsam
dort einen gang oder auch zwei gänge zu
schalten wo es sinn macht den
bundesstaatlichen gefüge mit starken
kommunen geht es nur im konsens deshalb
bin ich auch gespannt auf die beschlüsse
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz zu
planungs beschreibungen will auch ganz
klar sagen unsere erwartung an dem
ministerpräsidenten ist das muss ein
großer wurf wert die zentrale frage
lautet wo können wir bei einzelnen
anforderungen und auflagen ein stück
weit zurückfahren weil es in einer
gesamtbetrachtung sinn macht beim
ausgleich zwischen investitionen für den
klimaschutz sowie dem arten- und
naturschutz sind zum beispiel schlankere
verfahren dort geboten wo die positiven
ökologischen gesamt auswirkungen eines
abends dies rechtfertigen und auch bei
einem anderen thema ist die
bundesregierung gefordert oft ist ja so
wenn die dinge nach dem gesunden
menschenverstand eigentlich klar
erscheinen dann werden gerne
europäisches recht oder völkerrecht
bemüht das heißt bei den vorgaben zur
umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung bei der
verbandsklage wurde beim umweltrechts
per headset das aber ist nicht mein
anspruch an politik nicht erwarte von
einer bundesregierung dass sie sich auf
europäischer und auf internationaler
ebene mutig und engagiert für
anpassungen am rechtsrahmen einsetzt
wenn diese geboten sind
und in meinen augen sind diese zwingend
geboten der europäische green deal
verändert die geschäftsgrundlage
fundament halten die mitgliedstaaten
sollen ihre wirtschaft ihre
infrastruktur im rekordtempo
modernisieren und dekarbonisierung da
muss auch die eu größtes interesse an
einer verschlankung der wege und
verkürzung der verfahren haben also es
gibt viel zu tun und tätigkeit seit der
bundesregierung werde nicht nur
politisch unverständlich sondern würde
nachhaltigen entwicklung deutschland
schaden mit unserem antrag liegen
konkrete vorschläge auf dem tisch ich
bitte sie alle um unterstützung für
unsere forderung für eine gute zukunft
unseres landes
steffen bilger war es der
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
der unionsfraktion und die union hat
hier diesen antrag vorgelegt mit dem
titel leben planungs und
genehmigungsphase weiter beschleunigen
und jetzt hören wir was die spd dazu
sagt kassen träger
kollegen der demokratischen fraktionen
lieberherr reger vielen dank für den
antrag vielen dank für die mahnenden
worte eines der es wissen muss sie waren
ja immerhin lange jahre
parlamentarischer staatssekretär im
verkehrsministerium rahmen sie ganz ganz
viel im bereich planungs beschleunigung
und sie haben ja auch rwe korans nach
ihres sich gelegen hat da muss jetzt mal
die europäische union was machen also
vielen dank für den antrag vielen dank
dass wir dieses thema auf der
tagesordnung haben und ich kann ihnen
versichern sie ihre beruhigung wir sind
da dran an dem thema aber es steht
nämlich auch schon im koalitionsvertrag
und zwar an prominenter stelle von daher
immer gerne konstruktive mitarbeit
kennen wir ja aus vielen bereichen und
wir sind da offen bringen sie ihre
fortschritte vorschläge keine ein
immerhin steht in dem antrag der einiges
drin diese koalition arbeitet mit
hochdruck daran und wir haben als
wollten sie auch wissen eines der
zentralen themen ist natürlich der
beschleunigte ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien wir haben gerade eine lange
debatte dazu verfolgt da ging es dann
darum dass wir unabhängig werden müssen
von russischen gas vom russischen
energieimporten und ich sage dazu wir
haben es auf die tagesordnung gesetzt
weil wir wollen bei der bekämpfung des
klimawandels schneller werden wollen
viel schneller als wir es in der
vergangenheit mit ihnen gemeinsam
geschafft haben
16 jahre hat sparen 16 jahre waren
verantwortung alles die spd schuld ist
schon klar diese fortschritts koalition
hat in sechs monaten mehr geschafft als
sie in 16 jahren
vielleicht erinnern sie sich noch an
einen energie- und wirtschaftsminister
der his peter altmaier der durfte ja
nicht mal eine kalkulation des
energiebedarfs vorlegen weil die
unionsfraktion im das verboten hat erst
am ende der legislaturperiode also
sozusagen nicht mehr daran diese
festgebunden war da hat er dann eine
berechnung vorgelegt das war so wie
geben etwas spät und zwar auch noch viel
zu niedrig also wir dagegen handeln wir
handeln extrem schnell vielleicht ist
ein gutes beispiel dafür dass lg gesetzt
dass wir heute abend in zweiter dritter
lesung beschließen werden wir werden der
verantwortung gerecht ist wir aufgrund
der zeitenwende schnell reagieren müssen
wir schaffen die möglichkeiten dass noch
in diesem winter schwimmen der lng
terminals ihre arbeit aufnehmen können
und dass wir damit einen entscheidenden
beitrag zu dieser energieunabhängigkeit
leisten werden und ich möchte das
beispiel auch noch an zweiter stelle
nennen weil es nämlich auch aufzeigt
dass wir eben nicht die dauer krisen
dieses planeten dabei aus dem blick
verlieren es gibt die arten krise und es
gibt den klimawandel und die müssen wir
natürlich bekämpfen und deswegen ist es
eine gute und richtige entscheidung dass
wir einerseits die schwimmenden germany
jetzt sehr sehr schnell ins werk setzen
auch unter aussetzung von umwelt und
anderen fach richten aber andererseits
bei den projekten die sowieso längere
baumaßnahmen sind die also mehrere
monate und jahre brauchen werden dass
wir dort eben das fachrecht nicht
schleifen und auch nicht aussetzen
sondern nur beschleunigen an den nötigen
stellen deswegen ist das finde ich ein
kluges und gutes und angemessenes
vorgehen in diesen zeiten in denen wir
sind
sie hingegen
haben in ihrem antrag drin sie setzen
auf ausnahmen sie setzen auf
einschränkungen und verschlechterungen
beim natur- und artenschutz über die
eingriffsregelung wollen sie eine
umgestaltung des naturschutzfachlichen
vermeidungs gebots und sie wollen den
verzicht höre höre höre auf den
naturschutzrechtlichen ausgleich damit
schaffen sie zentrale elemente des arten
und naturschutzes das ist ihre eigene
nationale antwort auf das thema planungs
und verfahrensbeschleunigung das ist
nicht unser weg und den gehen wir nicht
mehr
ich komme zum schluss
wir wollen schneller werden und sie
werden sehen bereits in der zweiten
jahreshälfte werden wir die nötigen
gesetze und verfahrensbeschleunigung
verabschieden weil nämlich hinter den
kulissen schon eifrig gearbeitet wird
deswegen herzlichen dank für ihren
beitrag wir setzen auch kürzere
verfahren wir setzen auf digitalisierung
wir setzen auf mehr personal wir setzen
auf standardisierung und beschleunigung
aber nicht auf das schleifen von
materiellen fach und umweltrecht vielen
dank der kasten träger von der spd hat
darauf hingewiesen dass allen die
beschleunigungsgesetz also das
beschleunigungsgesetz zur verfügung
machen von flüssiggas das soll heute
noch verabschiedet werden hier im
bundestag soll damit soll unter anderem
bewiesen werden angeschafft werden was
in deutschland eigentlich unmöglich ist
nämlich innerhalb von etwa zehn monaten
ein lng terminal also an flüssiggas
terminal zu errichten um es
anzuschließen an die deutsche
gasversorgung und deutschland versucht
eben in rekordzeit unabhängig von
russischem erdgas zu werden andreas
blick jetzt für die fdp
hatte kolleginnen und kollegen in bunten
bildern wenig klarheit wird um und ein
fünkchen wahrheit so wird der beste
trank gebraut der alle welt erquickt und
auf erbaut nach diesem rezept aus
goethes faust haben cdu und csu den
antrag geschrieben neben dem fünkchen
wahrheit stichwort digitalisierung der
verwaltung beinhaltet er viel youtube
stichwort artenschutz im spannungsfeld
zwischen klimaschutz auf der einen seite
und artenschutz auf der anderen seite
positionieren sich cdu und csu völlig
einseitig so fordern sie ähnlich wie spd
grüne und fdp den schutz von
populationen bei planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren das hört sich zwar
gut an ist aber schlecht denn beim
population schutz ist nicht der bessere
artenschutz sondern der schnellere
ausbau der sogenannten erneuerbaren
energien motor des gedankens nicht mehr
der einzelne rotmilan soll geschützt
werden sondern nur noch seine population
doch der europäische gerichtshof hat in
seinem urteil vom 14 märz 2021 den
individuen schutz gestärkt für den
ausbau von windkraftanlagen bleibt es
also bei einer individuen bezogenen
betrachtung auf der ebene des verbots
datenbestandes wer eine population
bezogene betrachtung möchte verstößen
gegen europäisches recht auch deshalb
sagen wir rotmilan stadt windkraft
worden darüber hinaus kaufen cdu und csu
der klimaschutzpolitische nutzen von
photovoltaik anlagen auf freiflächen
überwiege grundsätzlich dem naturschutz
politischen schaden doch das ist falsch
richtig ist unter bestimmten bedingungen
kann kann
der ausbau von photovoltaik anlagen
naturschutz verträglich gestaltet werden
doch das ist jedoch die ausnahme und
nicht die regel aus diesem grund sollten
für den ausbau von photovoltaik anlagen
dachflächen und nicht frei flächen
genutzt werden dass sie zudem einen
verzicht auf die naturschutzrechtlichen
ausgleich für energie infrastruktur
erfordern setzt dem ganzen noch die
krone auf sie etikettieren das als
modernisierter natur und artenschutz
dienen dass kastrierte natur und
artenschutz
des weiteren müssten cdu und csu das
verbandsklagerecht nicht nur auf
umweltbelange beschränken sondern auch
ausschließlich bei einer nicht
ordnungsgemäßen beteiligung der verbände
im planungsverfahren ermöglichen
klageberechtigt sollen nur verbände
seien die anerkannt sind höre höre
welche verwendet das wohl sein können
können wir uns alle vorstellen das
etikettieren sie in ihrem antrag als
effizientere bürgerbeteiligung wähnen
denn das inszenierte bürgerbeteiligung
werte kolleginnen und kollegen von cdu
und csu den titel ihres antrags nach
möchten sie einen beschleunigten
planungs und genehmigungsverfahren für
mehr wohlstand versorgungssicherheit und
ökologischen mehrwert doch diese ziele
werden sie mit den sogenannten
erneuerbaren energien nicht erreichen
wir haben bereits den höchsten
strompreis der welt wir haben bereits
steigende zahlen vom mut eingriffen in
das stromnetz und wir haben bereits eine
unter druck geratenen artenschutz ihr
antrag wird das alles noch verschlimmern
und obwohl ich weiß dass einige
abgeordnete ihrer fraktion ist besser
wissen erwähnen sie eine lösung für die
teilweise von ihnen mitverschuldeten
probleme nicht die kernenergie gemeinsam
mit der kohleverstromung nötig die
kernenergie einst den grundstein für den
wohlstand unseres landes und unserer
bürger der strompreis niedrig das
stromnetz stabil und im unterschied zu
windkraftanlagen
photovoltaikanlagen und kohlekraftwerken
wie von kernkraftwerke co2 freien und
grundlastfähigen strom
werte kolleginnen und kollegen seit der
zwanzigsten wahlperiode im deutschen
bundestag ist der umweltausschuss auch
für den verbraucherschutz zuständig den
antrag von cdu und csu könnten wie im
umweltausschuss auch unter
verbraucherschutz politischen
gesichtspunkten mit beraten denn es
besteht hier offensichtlich ein verdacht
auf etikettenschwindel und mogelpackung
vielen dank
das wort hat die kollegin christina
johann schröder für die fraktion bündnis
90 die grünen
sehr geehrte frau vorsitzende liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
ich habe ihren antrag liebe
cdu/csu-fraktion gelesen und dachte wow
die union hatte einen echten
erkenntnisprozess sie fordern
sie fordert den nachhaltigen umbau der
wirtschaft hin zur klimaneutralität den
schnellen ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien und wollen damit die
versorgungssicherheit in deutschland
sichern sie wollen einen besseren schutz
vor starkregen hochwasser akteure also
die folgen des klimawandels abmildern
sie die union wünschen sich strafen die
nicht von schlaglöchern übersät sind
brücken die man nicht schwer ist weil es
unter der last des verkehrs
zusammenbrechen und damit es weniger
verkehr gibt sondern auch pnv und
schienen infrastruktur ausgebaut werden
dabei denken sie nicht nur an diejenigen
die von a nach b kommen müssen sondern
an jene die unter lärm und abgasen
leiten wir befinden uns inmitten einer
großen wohnung sony preiskrise auch die
wollen sie lösen durch mehr bezahlbaren
geschosswohnungsbau nicht zuletzt
fordern sind diesem antrag die
landwirtschaft nutztierhaltung umzubauen
damit tiere nicht leiden sondern sich
entsprechend ihrer bedürfnisse
mit platz licht und luft bewegen können
liebe kolleginnen der union das finden
wir
ich habe mich nicht gefragt warum sie in
den letzten 16 jahren diese ziele nicht
umgesetzt haben ich war vielmehr sehr
daran interessiert
ich habe sehr
ich habe mich sehr dafür interessiert
was sie vorschlagen und muss feststellen
dass wir das ganz gut mit der spd insel
umsetzen
jede lösung sind halt beim alten
geblieben geblieben ihre zentrale lösung
und planungen in der bundesrepublik zu
beschleunigen sind weiterhin die
beschneidung von beteiligungsrechten
bürgerinnen und umweltverbände werden
weiterhin als planungs bremserin
abgewertet neu ist dass die beschneidung
der beteiligungsrechte mit ein bisschen
digitalisierung gar nette herr bilger
sie haben dass maßnahmen gesetz
vorbereitungs gesetz öffnet das hat nun
ein vertragsverletzungsverfahren der eu
gegen die bundesrepublik ausgelöst dass
dieses gesetz gegen die aarhus
konvention verstößt war schon während
des gesetzgebungsprozesses so gut wie
klar und das ist auch ein versuch um
maßmann durchzudrücken wie die weser
vertiefung gegen die
parteiübergreifend alle parteien vor ort
sind und ein normales
planfeststellungsverfahren nicht
überleben würden wichtiger maßnahmen
hingegen die wir dringend brauchen
werden dadurch bestand fertig kollegin
so wird das nichts
durch die ampel regierung wurde der pakt
für planungs und genehmigungs und
umsetzungs beschleunigten bereits
gestartet die beschleunigung von
planungs und genehmigungsprozesse das
ist chefsache bei uns das kanzleramt
risch forstet mit den staatssekretären
bestehende gesetze plan verschlanken und
analysierte sachgerecht die ursachen für
zu lange genehmigungsprozesse es ist
beinahe nicht zu glauben dass praktisch
alle gesetze zu einer bürokratisierung
und zur planungs beschleunigung nicht
sachgerecht evaluiert wurden und da
kommen wir zu wesentlichen fragen dieser
debatte warum verzögern sich planung in
deutschland
das ist wichtig es liegt nicht an der
demokratischen legitimation an
bürgerinnen und beteiligungsrechten
dieser mythos der gehört in den
verstaubten aktenschrank
das schnelle planung und deutschland mit
einer effektiv arbeiten regierung
möglich ist zeigen gesetze die wir
aktuell beraten zum ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien und auch zu den ln
sie türmen sich um menschen im kommenden
winter eine warme wohnung zu bieten und
der industrie die notwendige prozess
werden wir werden die dialogische
kompetenz für beteiligungsverfahren
stärken und die eigenen
beratungskapazitäten den ländern und
kommunen zur verfügung stehen
frühzeitige verfahrens kompetenzen
zwischen vorhaben trägerinnen anhörungs
und genehmigungsbehörden werden
grundsätzlich etabliert in gerichtliche
auseinandersetzung zu minimieren
behörden wenn endlich mit der
notwendigen technik ausgestattet damit
daten zur kartierung und zum artenschutz
übergreifend und lange nutzbar sind und
zentral zugänglich das
raumordnungsgesetz wird modernisieren
und das baugesetzbuch und das erst nicht
zum ende der legislaturperiode
ein grund für verzögerungen in der
planung und genehmigung ist sicherlich
auch die personelle ausstattung
deswegen ist eine ausbildungs und
fortbildungsinitiative ein zentraler
bestandteil der
planungsbeschleunigungsgesetz
koalitionsvertrages wird die
beschleunigung von planungs und
genehmigungsprozesse behandelt wir
messen dem einen hohen wert zu und wir
werden das verlorene vertrauen von
gesellschaft und wirtschaft zurück
gewinnen und zwar ohne
und zwar ohne bürgerrechte zu schleifen
oder schutzgüter in frage zu stellen
ihnen dann
das wort hat der kollege klaus ernst für
die fraktion die linke
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die insbesondere von der cdu
csu fraktion ist erfordern die
beschleunigung von planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren
hier möchte die mir zu sprechen
wir alle wollen dass die bürger wollen
dass wie kriegen wir die sich um das
hinzukriegen brauchen vor allen dingen
eine abgesicherte finanzielle
ausstattung der länder des bundes unter
verwaltung
zweiter wir brauchen wir brauchen
qualifiziertes und motiviertes personal
wenn ein kommunales bauland aus
vermeintlichen geldmangel keine den
bauingenieur mehr einstellen dort können
straßen brücken und schulen eben nicht
erneuert werden woher kommt der mangel
meine damen und herren ich hab den
eindruck für den mangelnden wir haben
ist insbesondere ihre ideologie des
schlanken staates kaputtgespart staates
verantwortlich
und es ist schon bemerkenswert was jetzt
hier machen irgendwie finde ich sehr
amüsant sie kommen jetzt hier und sagen
doch funktioniert alles nicht da gibt es
mängel das sind mengen die sie durch
ihren fremde die sie in diesen bereichen
gelegt haben selbst verantwortlich für
selbst verantwortlich sind und jetzt
wollen sie feuerwehr spielen ich habe
den eindruck dies kommt daher weil sie
wissen ja es gibt ja da ihm recht zu
eine position da heißt es wenn ein
brandstifter beim löschen hielt der
täter straffrei aus
vielleicht ist die motivation für diesen
antrag
sie fordern unter anderem investitionen
in die verkehrswege die ertüchtigung von
straßen die verbesserung der
schieneninfrastruktur den ausbau des
nahverkehrs
das wundert mich jetzt doch nicht dass
ich was gegen diese forderungen hätte im
gegenteil
vielleicht darf ich den satz noch zu
ende machen
das wundert mich jetzt doch
ich freue mich aber auch warum warum
haben wir das eigentlich nicht längst
ich weiß nicht unter dem anderer steht
steht jetzt mehr zu dieser doppel redet
ihr eigentlich nicht miteinander könnten
sie immer sagen wird er verkehrsminister
zuletzt
gestellt ist der ist leichter ist der
iss an
und ich frage mich wo die eigentlich ist
die anti shock also nicht
ich habe viermal den verkehrsminister
gesetzt und die heldenreise ist ja
relativ lang vier mal sind sie für all
das verantwortlich was sie in diesem
antrag bemängelt dass die show 30
prozent quote halte ich habe jetzt die
uhr angehalten und trage so der stadt
muss ich eine bemerkung oder das
vorliegen heime die zurück das kündigt
ja bitte
vielen dank dass in die frage zu lassen
sie haben jetzt gesagt wir seien der
brandstifter weil wir kürzungen beim
personal tagen die sie vielleicht wissen
war ich bevor ich im deutschen bundestag
war justizsenator des landes berlin
folgend eine rot rote regierung die
meinen bereich um 700 stellen gekürzt
hat gegen unseren widerstand und ich
musste das aufräumen und eines der
gründe für die verfahrensverzögerung
berlin lag genau darin warum wir daran
schuld sein sollen wo das dach in den
ländern stattfindet auch im osten sehr
stark unter beteiligung der damaligen
pds heute linke
was heimat war das für die cdu
eigentlich ganz einfach sagen die sie
entscheidend ist ja nicht so zu sagen in
welchem land was passiert ist sondern
entscheidend ist welche ideologie sich
in diesem land durchgesetzt hat die
ideologie und die ideologie die sie
durchgesetzt haben war die ideologie am
effektivsten ist ein staat wenn er sich
möglichst wenig sozusagen selbst in
verantwortung nimmt was er tut ein
schlanker staat das war ihre ideologie
und diese schlanke staat hat dazu
geführt dass wir in den verwaltungen
dass wir in den verwaltungen übrigens
auf allen ebenen die ideologie von ihnen
zieht sie durch bis in die letzte
kommune übrigens auch bei der bundeswehr
wenn sie jetzt beklagen dass die zu
wenig unter großen händen habe erhalten
verteidigung ist ja um geführt man den
namen wird ja in der letzten zeit also
sie haben denn sie haben dem schlanken
staat propagiert und das ergebnis dieses
schlanken staat ist jetzt das was sie
bemängeln und deshalb sage ich dieser
antrag der ist nicht so ganz
verständlich sie könnten zumindest mit
ein wenig demut an die sache gehen sie
können zum beispiel sorgen dass dies so
ist haben wir selbst verursacht dann
wäre es glaubwürdiger und jetzt haben
wir einen wandel vollzogen das machen
sie alles nicht sondern sie stellen sich
ebenso das was alles ist das ist alles
nicht und haben selbst zu verantworten
deshalb sage ich sie sind brandstifter
und wollen feuerwehr so damit ist die
frage beantwortet und jetzt komme ich
nochmal zum und jetzt komme ich nochmal
zum steuern der scheuer ist ja das ist
schon nochmal punkt also der hat ja nun
wenn ich es richtig sehe
500 millionen als eine halbe milliarde
ist letztendlich der steuerzahler jetzt
in der in der verantwortung für das was
dir ausgegeben hat
jetzt hat er auch noch ein verfahren
haben halt wo sie eigentlich immerhin
ist er hier oder woanders hin sitzen
also
das zeigt doch bitteschön das zeigt doch
bitte schön dass das was da gelaufen ist
offensichtlich nicht ganz korrekt war
sie fordern richten sie fordern
richtigerweise den schnellen ausbau
erneuerbarer energien ich lasse jetzt
die mängel artenschutz ist alles schon
gesagt dass die energiewende war in den
letzten jahren im wirtschaftsausschuss
corinna vorsitzender dass nun das heißt
dass ihr mit eurem koalitionspartner
drin der koalitionspartner hat bemängelt
und kritisiert dass es sozusagen bei
euch jetzt vorwärts geht sondern dass
ihr die bremse war in den punkten die
jetzt bemängelt also passt nicht so
natürlich und experimente was der
polizei und jetzt stellt ihr euch hin
und sagt jetzt müssen wir aber ganz
schnell vorankommen das ist alles nicht
sehr glaubwürdig
kollegen und kollegen und sagte immer
vorgeworfen wenn wir einen vorschlag
machen dann sagen wir das geld herkommt
habt ihr habt keinen einzigen vorschlag
gewesen das geld bekommt keinen einzigen
jetzt kommt ja sein dass er auf märz
vertraut also
im hintergrund ich glaube das
funktioniert und wenn das aber so ist
meine damen und herren dann könne nicht
sagen der antrag den sie vorgelegt haben
da ist wirklich eher amüsant als ganz zu
geben herzlichen dank
klaus ernst war das für die linke hat er
gesprochen als vorsitzender des
ausschuss für klimaschutz und energie
hier im bundestag
und hat sich hier sowohl der union als
auch die ampel koalition vorgenommen hat
die liberalen der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende es hier im haus
eine große einigkeit welche
infrastrukturprojekte wir gemeinsam
angehen wollen um den klimawandel zu
bekämpfen die energiewende
voranzutreiben wollen wir erneuerbare
energien ausbauen um dabei zu helfen
dass mehr menschen bezahlbaren wohnraum
finden brauchen wir mehr bezahlbare
wohnung und die müssen gebaut werden wir
müssen die netze bauen sowohl im bereich
der digitalisierung glasfaser als auch
im bereich des stroms aber wir müssen
uns auch kümmern um die frage was ist
eigentlich die voraussetzung dafür und
wenn es uns nicht gelingt planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren zu beschleunigen
dann können wir uns all diese projekte
an den hut stecken
das wird nicht hinhauen und deswegen ist
es gut dass wir heute morgen über
planungs und genehmigungsbescheid
einigung spricht und man hätte sich
wahrscheinlich keinen besseren tag
aussuchen können um über dieses thema zu
sprechen weil heute abend diese
diskussion hier im haus eine fortsetzung
findet mit der beratung des lng aus
baugesetzes des beschleunigungsgesetz es
vielen dank dafür
denn mit diesem problem zeigt die ampel
dass es möglich ist in einem bestimmten
bereich zügig ein beschleunigungs
verfahren voranzubringen hier geht es
darum schneller unabhängig zu werden von
russischem erdgas um schneller eine
eigene infrastruktur
auf die schiene zu setzen und
vorzubereiten und plötzlich ist es
möglich in krisenzeiten geht es dann
dass man auf die
umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung in
bestimmten bereichen verzichtet sie
nachholt und das ganze schneller macht
und diese kreativität diesen
pragmatismus den wünschen wir uns auch
in anderen bereichen was bei lng
terminals geht das muss auch bei straßen
geben das muss auch bei brücken gehen
das muss auch bei windenergie geben das
muss auch bei wohnungen gehen das muss
in allen anderen bereichen aufgehen und
deswegen sollten wir uns genau anschauen
was da heute abend beraten wird gucken
wo kann man s übertragen auf andere
bereiche und da macht die ampel sehr
gute vorschläge die man sich dann zum
beispiel dem kann für andere bereiche
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen all das
was wir im bereich der planungs
beschleunigung machen muss natürlich mit
der rechtsstaatlichen grundsätzen
vereinbar seien und ja wir haben auch im
bereich der innen und rechtspolitik
vieles vor um die planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren in deutschland zu
beschleunigen ich nenne stellvertretend
erster die entfristung des planungs
sicherstellung des gesetzes im
geschäftsbereich des bmi ich nenne
stellvertretend ihre form der
verwaltungsgerichtsordnung aus dem
geschäftsbereich des bmj das ist alles
das ist alles richtig aber wir müssen
auch hinterfragen warum andere staaten
in europa wie dänemark und die
niederlande die das gleiche europarecht
haben wie hier mit so viel weniger
einwendungen klarkommen das hat etwas
damit zu tun dass es in diesen staaten
eine andere planungskultur gibt und
diese andere planungskultur die wollen
wir auch in deutschland etablieren und
da gibt es im koalitionsvertrag seite
zehn bis zwölf wahrscheinlich die besten
seiten des ganzen koalitionsvertrages
richten gute ideen wie man das machen
kann durch mehr digitalisierung die
kartierungs daten sind schon genannt
worden durch mehr schnittstellen
zwischen bund und ländern durch eine
personelle unterstützung durch eine per
sogar 2 durch eine personelle
unterstützung verschiedener ebenen und
auch durch eine finanzielle
unterstützung durch den angesprochenen
pakt für planungs und
genehmigungsbescheide das ist der
richtige weg den müssen wir einschlagen
und ich bin sehr dankbar dafür dass die
ampel koalition heute mit den ln
beschleunigungsgesetz einen ersten
schritt in die richtige richtung geht
und anschließend arbeiten wir dann
unseren koalitionsvertrag herzlichen
dank
ja und wie constantin coole eben gesagt
im koalitionsvertrag hat sich dass die
ampel ja auch auf die fahnen geschrieben
und vorgenommen auf die agenda
geschrieben nämlich dass die zeit für
planungs und genehmigungsverfahren
halbiert werden soll und der
bundeskanzler olaf scholz hat das selbst
gerade nochmal aktuell angekündigt dass
auch noch in diesem jahr werde die
bundesregierung dazu die nötigen
entscheidungen treffen und in die wege
leiten dank dass sie unserem antrag
zustimmen werden denn das was sie jetzt
genannt haben konnten sie bei uns und
können sie bei uns lesen wir freuen uns
auf die unterstützung der fdp bei
unserem antrag herzlichen dank dafür und
dem kollegen träger möchte ich einfach
in erinnerung rufen und dann ist das
thema auch durch 16 - 4 macht zwölf ganz
einfach zu rechnen auch für die spd und
dann sage ich schulze hendrix gabriele
und jeder weiß was gemeint ist stehlen
sie sich nicht permanent aus der
verantwortung stehen sie zu dem wie sie
mit uns zusammen regiert haben liebe
kollegen
lebens
verkehrswege sind lebenswege und
lebensadern sie sind grundlage für
unseren wohlstand für unsere wirtschaft
und sie gehören natürlich zu den
kernaufgaben des staates dafür zu sorgen
sie zu erhalten sie anzupassen sie
auszubauen und das unter den
lebensbedingungen und
lebensrealitäten der menschen vor ort
und liebe kollegin früh das ehrt sie 38
punkte im koalitionsvertrag
wir sind der meinung das ist spitze und
ich habe ihnen wie es vor ort laufen wir
vor ort werden vor ort werden sie wieder
da sein und sagen geht nicht machen wir
nicht bürgerinitiative ich machte mir
mal ein ganz einfaches beispiel
ausbau eines bahnhofs barrierefrei
wollen wir alle zehn jahre planung dann
klage unterstützt vor den grünen ich
hätte es nicht glauben können aber es
war bei mir vor ort in meiner
heimatstadt da wäre ich an ihrer stelle
einfach ruhiger es nützt nichts wenn sie
in berlin papier füllen aber vor ort
anders handeln liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen das sind genau die dinge die
die menschen die die menschen
frustrieren und das sind genau die dinge
warum wir auch planungs beschleunigung
brauchen wir brauchen sie bei den netzen
wir brauchen sie im schienenverkehr es
funktioniert kein umstieg wenn ich nicht
hätte die planung genehmige wie sollen
denn die ganzen takt verbindungen
geschaffen werden wenn ich für jede
weiche zehn jahre brauche und das hat
natürlich etwas auch mit präzision zu
tun herr kollege coole das hat was mit
rechtsstaat zu tun präzision und hat was
mit rechtssicherheit zu tun und genau an
dieser stelle müssen wir ansetzen ewige
verfahren werden von den menschen nicht
mehr akzeptiert werden sie sind isaac
ist teilweise sogar
demokratiegefährdend weil die menschen
nicht mehr glauben dass wir mit unseren
beschlüssen und unseren gesetzen dann in
der lage sind tatsächlich vor ort etwas
durchzusetzen etwas umzusetzen und
deswegen freuen wir uns auch da deswegen
freuen wir uns auch da auf die
unterstützung einer rechtsstaatspartei
weil wir wissen was rechtssicherheit im
planungsverfahren bedeutet um das auch
bei der plan beschleunigung liebe
kolleginnen problem
wenn wir erreichen wollen dass planungs
beschleunigung gelingt dann heißt es
natürlich abwägen aber dann heißt es
auch nach einer entscheidung einen punkt
machen und umsetzen und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen genau dafür
sind viele der punkte in unserem antrag
gedacht sie sind natürlich eine
fortentwicklung auch dessen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der spd was wir
mit vier planungsbeschleunigungsgesetz
in der letzten periode begonnen haben
und da war es jetzt nicht so dass sie
die beschleuniger waren sondern die
beschleunigung bei der planungs
beschleuniger war tatsächlich die union
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen sie haben
im koalitionsvertrag sich vorgenommen
die verfahrensdauer
mindeste zu halbieren der kollege ernst
lacht dazu keine sorge die kontrolle in
der nächsten periode ob es gelungen ist
wird die linke nicht mehr machen dass
sie nicht mehr da dass das wird sich
dann froh hier wieder abspielen ob es
gelungen ist sie zu halbieren wir bieten
heute vorschläge wir bieten ihnen mit
diesem antrag die möglichkeit gemeinsam
auf den weg zu gehen geben sie das
startsignal für planungs beschleunigung
geben sie das startsignal den menschen
dass in diesem land etwas umgesetzt
werden kann es ist keine zeit mehr zu
verlieren wenn wir diesen umbau in
unserer gesellschaft in unserem land
möchten in diesem sinne los geht's
dankeschön die union will die
möglichkeit für bürger erschweren
juristisch gegen planungsverfahren
vorzugehen gelingen soll dies laut
antrag auch ulrich lange hat es gerade
noch mal erwähnt durch die
wiedereinführung der präzision präzision
das heißt dass bürger und verbände ihre
einwände nur während des
planungsverfahrens vorbringen können
meine damen und herren seit sich die
union in der opposition mit der
beschleunigung von planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren befasst zeigt sie
eine erstaunliche lernkurve ich will sie
dazu erst mal herzlich beglückwünschen
und das sage ich auch als hesse liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wo sie
jahrelang vor der verspargelung der
landschaft gewarnt haben und davor dass
windräder höher sind als kirchtürme
verglichen damit sind das hier ganz neue
töne die sie an den tag legen herzlichen
glückwunsch dazu
ein paar gute ideen liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen machen aber noch kein
schlüssiges konzept manches müssen sie
da auch noch in den eigenen reihen
klären und es reicht ein blick nach
bayern um festzustellen dass die union
nicht das gaspedal zur bedeutet zur
beschleunigung der energiewende ist
sondern die bremse liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
in bayern bleibt es nämlich beim
grundsatz dass der abstand zwischen
wohnbebauung und windrad
regelmäßig die zehnfache der anlage
betragen muss das sind häufig 2 km und
ich frage sie wo sollen denn da
eigentlich die ganzen windräder gebaut
werden mit der restlosen abschaffung der
10h regungen wäre für die beschleunigung
mehr getan als mit dem antrag den sie
hier heute vorgelegt haben
in vielen punkten folgen sie jetzt der
koalition an anderen stellen liest man
wirkungslose vorschläge oder gedanken
die häufig nicht zu ende gedacht sind
zum beispiel klar gegründet die zu einem
frühen zeitpunkt nicht vorgebracht
worden sind für das weitere verfahren
auszuschliessen ist in der sache richtig
aber auch nichts neues dass
europarechtskonform zu gestalten ist die
eigentliche herausforderung der sich
auch die ampel koalition angenommen hat
oder warum öffentlich private
partnerschaften oder neue
auskunftsansprüche von behörden zu
schnelleren genehmigungs entscheidungen
führen sollen das wissen sie
wahrscheinlich selbst auch nicht so
genau um die modernisierung des landes
voran zu bringen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wollen wir die dauer bis zur
realisierung von projekten halbieren
dafür müssen wir jeden stein umdrehen
ich sage aber auch das was wir tun muss
am ende auch funktionieren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
sie schlagen unter anderem vor dass
klagen gegen den ausbau
der leitungsnetze der erneuerbaren
energien der wasserstoff-infrastruktur
und wichtige
verkehrsinfrastrukturprojekte
keine aufschiebende wirkung haben sollen
wissen sie eigentlich was das bedeutet
wenn sie diese ausnahme zur regel machen
ich kann ihnen das sagen fakten schaffen
auf kosten der rechtssicherheit haben
die klagen erfolgen müssen sie die
anlagen anschließend wieder zurückbauen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das
bringt kein mehr an tempo das verwandelt
unser land in eine einzige baustelle
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wie beschleunigung funktionieren kann
das stichwort ist ja schon gefallen das
zeigen wir bei flüssiggas aber auch bei
vielen neuerungen im rahmen des oster
pakets und da wollen wir im laufe des
jahres weiter machen es gilt die
richtigen schwerpunkte zu setzen und
drei davon wenn ich ihnen denn erstens
die digitalisierung muss endlich in der
verwaltung ankommen ist es bittere
realität dass sich in unseren behörden
die aktenordner mit planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren stapeln ist es
realität dass diese papierakten jahre
lang von büro zu büro gereicht werden
diese verfahren müssen schnellstmöglich
digitalisiert werden der kollege coole
hat es ja auch gesagt während der
pandemie haben wir gesehen dass das
funktionieren kann das plan sicher
stellungs gesetz hat die digitale
öffentlichkeitsbeteiligung ermöglicht
dahinter dürfen wir nicht mehr zurück
die wir verlegen und
zweitens wir müssen das verhältnis von
klima und artenschutz klären liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wer glaubt das
ist der richtige weg ist arten und
klimaschutz im planungsverfahren
gegeneinander auszuspielen der vergisst
dass die bekämpfung der erderwärmung der
beste schutz zur rettung bedrohter arten
ist
eine vielzahl von umwelt- und
rechtlichen aspekten wird folglich im
selben verfahren mehrfach geprüft das
ist in erster linie eins nämlich
zeitverschwendung verschwendung von zeit
die wir nicht haben wenn es um die
modernisierung unseres landes geht liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und drittens
behörden und gerichte brauchen personal
eines muss klar sein straffere verfahren
bringen nichts wenn in den behörden
niemand ist der diese verfahren
bearbeitet schnelle genehmigung bringen
nichts wenn in den gerichten niemand ist
um sie zu überprüfen eine
personaloffensive ist überfällig sie
muss kommen und sie wird auch kommen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
eines möchte ich den autorinnen und
autoren des antrags klassen die analyse
stimmt wir haben keine zeit zu verlieren
wenn es um die beschleunigung von
verfahren und in der konsequenz damit
und den ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
und entschieden ausbau und die
modernisierung unseres landes geht und
genau deswegen berät dieses parlament
auch nicht irgendwann sondern jetzt die
reformgesetze der koalition und die
nächsten stehen schon in den
startlöchern
wir freuen uns liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen von der unionsfraktion wenn sie
uns dabei unterstützen und wenn sie dann
auch noch beizeiten auf ihre kolleginnen
und kollegen in bayern ein wirken dann
wäre das ganz großartig ich danke ihnen
für die aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
das wort hat der abgeordnete carsten
hilfe für die afg fraktion
sind meine damen und herren liebe
landsleute
so dreist wie die sie von union muss man
erst mal sein so wie sie in ihrer
scheune oppositionsrolle plötzlich
bemerken dass beispielsweise
ungezügelten zuwanderung oder die
abschaltung von kernkraftwerken nicht
die besten ideen sind stellen die es
eine antrag auf beschleunigung von
planungs und genehmigungsverfahren
ganz so als ob sie nicht nur die letzten
16 jahre in der regierung gesessen
hätten sondern noch dazu alles getan
haben um die bürger die zum beispiel im
ausbauen wollten mit immer neuen
gesetzen und vorschriften für den
klimaschutz in den wahnsinn die behörden
und gewerke in verzweiflung und die
kosten in ungeahnte höhen getrieben
hätten frei nach dem motto
was interessiert mich mein geschwätz von
gestern nur mit dem großen unterschied
dass der sich mit wirklichen problemen
herumschlagen musste und deshalb seine
meinung änderte um sie dann erfolgreich
anzugehen und zu lösen sie aber jan
gemeinsam mit den grünen kommunisten der
ampel einem phantom problem namens
menschengemachter klimakatastrophe nach
und wollen die transformation unserer
industrie vorantreiben was allein deren
abwanderung zur folge hätte und mit ihr
den verlust von millionen hoch
wertschöpfender arbeitsplätze adenauer
handelte im interesse deutschlands sie
im interesse der korrupte lobbyisten wie
wir sie leider auch in diesem parlament
finden
natürlich ist es richtig
planungsverfahren zu beschleunigen
allerdings sind einige von ihnen
vorgeschlagene mittel nicht nur
ungeeignet sie erinnern auch in fataler
weise an die einer demokratie unwürdigen
vorgehensweisen wie zum beispiel in der
ehemaligen ddr und dem heutigen china
nicht umsonst hat er haarig in einem
interview die von ihm mit sicherheit
ernst gemeinte frage aufgeworfen ob
unsere demokratie oder der
staatsdirigismus aller china besser
geeignet wären maßnahmen gegen die
vermeintliche klimakatastrophe zu
erzwingen gegen den willen der
betroffenen koste es was es wolle und
wenn es das eigene volk ist im interview
hat sicher habe ich zwar zur demokratie
bekannt ist erkennen wir natürlich an
einige der ergriffenen maßnahmen
allerdings sind meilensteine in richtung
chinesische verhältnisse und die union
macht auch noch vorschläge wie wir am
schnellsten dorthin kommen um den
berechtigten widerstand beispielsweise
gegen das gegen die natur zerstören den
vogel töten und krankmachenden ungetüme
zu brechen sollen klagen nur bei over
verwaltungsgerichten eingereicht werden
dürfen und die klage keine aufschiebende
wirkung mehr haben sollten alle
forderungen ihres antrags umgesetzt
werden würden sie damit den wohlstand
nicht erhalten sondern in erheblichem
maße vernichten einem blog blackout
einem großen schritt näher kommen und
unsere natur in nie dagewesenem umfang
zerstören verabschieden sich von der
klima ideologie machen sie vorschläge
wie wir unsere wirtschaft wichtigen
unseren wohlstand erhalten und unsere
natur schützen dann haben sie uns auf
ihrer seite solange sie sich aber an der
faktischen vernichtung deutschlands
beteiligen werden wir sie werden wir sie
und ihre pläne natürlich mit
demokratischen mitteln bekämpfen zum
erhalt unserer heimat und zum wohle
unseres volkes ich bedanke mich für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
das wort hat der kollege lukas werner
für die fraktion bündnis 90
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die aktuelle
lage ist uns allen klar der krieg in der
ukraine die abhängigkeit von fossiler
energie von diktatoren und steigende
energiepreise der bundeskanzler hat hier
heute morgen gesagt dass mittel- und
langfristig der einzig vernünftige weg
die unabhängigkeit von fossiler energie
ist und der weg in die energie über
wenig hält und genau deswegen ist es
doch klar dass wir im bereich planungs
beschleunigungen da anfangen wo der
schuh am meisten drückt das wir im
energiebereich anfangen liebe
unionsfraktion und es ist schön dass sie
das thema für sich entdeckt haben dass
sie jetzt auch bei der planung
beschleunigung mitmachen wollen und als
inspiration für ihren antrag diente sehr
offensichtlich der koalitionsvertrag ist
ein kompliment dass die ampel sie
überzeugt weil sie unsere ideen in ihren
antrag schreiben
sie haben 16 jahre liiert sie haben
dafür
sie haben 60 jahre dienten 16 jahren die
chance gehabt etwas zu ändern jetzt sind
wir an der reihe und wir haben drei
zentrale punkte wie wir nach vorne gehen
wollen als erstes ist dass die
digitalisierung von verfahren das clan
sicherstellung gesetz hat eine grundlage
gelegt das müssen wir evaluieren denn
weiter entwickeln wir brauchen digitale
verfahren das zweite ist die personelle
ausstattung
wir sehen das ist in der exekutive an
personalmangel und noch schlimmer ist
mangelt am ende auch an den gewichten an
personal so dass nach klagen nicht über
die verfahren entschieden werden will
und da wollen wir angehen zum einen mit
dem pakt für den rechtsstaat wollen die
justiz entlasten und zum anderen mit den
pakt für planungs genehmigungs
beschleunigung und dem nicht und wir
wollen in diesem jahr noch die grundlage
legen für neue stellen am
bundesverwaltungsgericht damit wir für
schnelle entscheidungen sorgen können
der dritte punkt die vereinheitlichung
von auslegung denn bei rechtssicherheit
geht es immer darum dass die behörden
recht auf einheitlich um klar auslegen
und da müssen wir mit auslegungs hilfen
vorangehen und helfen das in den
behörden im ganzen land gleiche
entscheidungen getroffen werden liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen es ist aber
nicht so dass wir gerade erst anfangen
die häuser arbeitet mit hochdruck daran
das thema planungs beschleunigung
voranzubringen das oster paket hat die
erste grundlage gelegt im sommer paket
kommen die großen maßnahmen für
beschleunigung und das eckpunktepapier
vogelschutz und windkraft zeigt doch in
welche richtung wir gehen wollen und es
geht in ihrem antrag liege union vor
allen dingen auch darum den umweltschutz
zurückzufahren das kann aber doch nicht
das ziel sein wir können doch nicht auf
kosten von umweltschutz die planungs
beschleunigung voranbringen wir wollen
doch klimaschutz mit und für den
umweltschutz machen der andere wichtige
punkt ist wir müssen die frühe
beteiligung nach vorne bringen bei frühe
beteiligung der bürgerinnen und bürger
beugt fehlern fuhr und sorgt für mehr
akzeptanz in unserem verfahren unser
ansatz ist es mehr personal strafe
verfahren anstatt dies fordern weniger
umweltschutz und ausbleibende
beteiligung
aber liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir
können hier verbleiben zu beschleunigen
sehr sehr viel tun und das werden wir
auch die währung der energiewende ist
aber die fläche und deswegen geben sie
ihren antrag doch mal an die bayerische
staatskanzlei sorgen sie doch dafür dass
die zehnjährige state denn wir brauchen
die flächen auf denen mit dem schnellen
verfahren aufgebaut werden kann
und deswegen
deswegen geht es darum dass wir das hier
als gesamtgesellschaftliche aufgabe
verstehen dass wir mit allen häusern
gemeinsam die grundlage schaffen die
planungs beschleunigung voranzubringen
und dass sie auch in ihre länder dafür
sorgen dass wir flächen zur verfügung
gestellt bekommen damit am ende auch
anlagen gebaut werden können wir sind an
den konzern bleibe ich gewänder ich habe
die uhr angehalten gestatten sie eine
bemerkung oder frage des abgeordneten
hilse nein danke
und deswegen geht es doch darum dass wir
die planungs beschwörung jetzt mit allen
häusern angehen es läuft bereits liebe
union ich freue mich auf ihren input
weil es kann nicht versprechen da kommt
sehr sehr viel in den nächsten wochen
und monaten vielen dank
lukas werner ach ja für die
bündnisgrünen und wie schon diverse
redner der ampel koalition vor ihm hat
er nochmal darauf hingewiesen was die
regierungskoalition angeschoben hat und
dass das versprechen im
koalitionsvertrag die planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren von der zeit hier
zu halbieren so zu sagen doch in arbeit
sei das ganze umzusetzen du kannst
köhler jetzt für die fdp
ist der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
lieben damen und herren
lieber ernst sie haben eben darüber
gesprochen welche zu seinen formen der
staat aus jeder sicht haben wollen ich
bin einzig tal bei ihnen dass der der
staat handlungsfähig sein muss aber den
gedanken fand ich schon interessant
darüber zu sprechen wäre für uns muss
der staat sein wie ein antiker
griechischer er muss schlank sein auf
der einen seite und stark auf der
anderen seite er muss da schlank sein wo
es die menge an regeln gibt die dinge
behindern die uns daran behindern
schnell zu sein die regeln müssen so gut
sein wie es geht es geht ja nicht darum
dass der staat nicht an uns gerichtet
ist sondern dass das was er regelt klar
reguliert es ist eindeutig ein leuchten
zu verstehen ist schnell in der
umsetzung er muss aber da stark sein
wenn er die dinge umsetzt
jetzt können wir uns fragen sind wir in
deutschland in einer situation in der
das der fall ist und aktuell auch nach
16 jahren missmanagement sind wir nicht
in dieser situation wir sind nicht
schnell wir sind nicht guter dinge fix
hinzustellen wir sind gut wenn sie dann
mal stehen dann sind sie hervorragend
weil deutsche ingenieurinnen und
ingenieure deutsche schaffenskraft
deutschen ingenieurs cup deutsche
innovationskraft dafür sorgt dass das
was wir tun dann hervorragend aber bis
wir es getan haben dort war das können
wir nicht da ist wir planen
und wir tun wir machen und wir gehen
vorwärts und ich weiß nicht alle
kolleginnen und kollegen die meisten
menschen in deutschland kennen das
problem wenn sie versuchen eine
solaranlage auf dem dach zu bauen oder
wenn sie mit jemandem darüber sprechen
ja das tut oder wenn sie versuchen ein
renovierung durchzuführen oder wenn sie
irgendetwas anderes tun wollen dann
haben sie zwei problem das eine ist die
riesige bürokratische hürde um das zu
tun egal was macht das zweite ist dass
sie zu wenig fachkräfte haben dass sie
zu wenig menschen haben die daran
arbeiten und das ist eine
herausforderung
herausfordernd wie auf der einen seite
heißt ist gut es wird in der zukunft
viele zum beispiel gute arbeitsplätze im
handwerksbereich geben das ist eine gute
nachricht für diejenigen die auf
jobsuche sind das eine gute nachricht
für diejenigen die in diesen tollen
berufen die es gibt arbeiten wollen aber
natürlich eine schlechte nachricht für
den umbau für die transformation ist
eine schlechte nachricht dafür dass wir
eben schneller werden und das ist es was
wir auf der einen seite an gibt aber auf
der anderen seite liegt darin auch eine
chance denn was wir in deutschland für
wirkliches wirtschaftswachstum brauchen
ist eine steigerung unserer
produktivität wir müssen mit der
arbeitskraft die wir haben schneller und
besser werden und nur wenn wir unsere
produktivität steigern dann steigt auch
unsere wirtschaftswachstum wieder und
vor der herausforderung stehen hier
meinen namen diese herausforderung
können wir durch unterschiedliche dinge
schaffen wir schaffen sie aber vor allen
dingen dadurch dass wir die
planfeststellungsverfahren verändern
dass wir in der planung in der
bereitstellung schneller das
energiegesetz dass wir heute abend
diskutieren würden weiß dass das beweist
aber auch und es dafür eine blaupause
was alles möglich ist was wir umsetzen
können einmal bei dingen die wir schnell
braun fsl use also schön mit termin ist
das ist das was wir unglaublich schnell
umsetzen auf der anderen seite aber
natürlich muss es rechtssicher seien und
deswegen ist es richtig dass stationäre
anlagen nicht bei der
umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung
gleichermaßen berücksichtigt werden weil
rechtssicherheit ist in diesem land
zentral und das bleibt achter und wenn
wir das wenn wir diese gemeinsame
gemeinsamkeiten produktivitätssteigerung
von einem schlanken aber starken start
wenn wir die ideen und die
schaffenskraft umsetzen dann meine damen
und herren können wir in deutschland
wirklich etwas erreichen das tun wir
gerade mit der ampel da freue ich mich
auch über die nächsten wochen und auch
über die weitere diskussion abonnieren
danke
lukas kohler war das für die fdp stellt
der fraktionsvorsitzende und der nächste
redner thomas heimann nämlich der hatte
sich ja schon mal mit einer
kurzintervention zu wort gemeldet hören
wir mal was er jetzt in seiner redezeit
hier noch am pult zu sagen hat für die
cdu csu fraktion
bürokratisch so langsam zu stark und zu
komplex organisiert das sagen wir nicht
heute mit dem antrag an das hat die cdu
csu fraktion vor zwei jahren in einem
buch neustadt das 300 seiten umfasst vor
zwei jahren festgestellt nicht heute
hier ernst wie ich will ihn kurz die
historie sagen wir haben auch in den
letzten legislaturperioden steffen
bürger darauf hingewiesen durchaus kluge
einzelmaßnahmen verabschiedet die zur
planungs beschleunigung in deutschland
beigetragen haben aber wir haben unser
ziel eindeutig nicht erreicht und unsere
große sorge ist dass die ampel ihre
ziele zur planungsbeschleunigungsgesetz
der maßnahmen die sie geschrieben haben
die auch in ihrem koalitionsvertrag
stehen und zu großen teilen wir ja auch
ja sagen und ich will begründen woran
das liegt das problem ist nämlich größer
als wir gedacht haben und auch größer
als sie es jetzt beschreiben wir haben
eine verkrustung und eine problem
komplexität mit der wir nur
zurechtkommen werden wenn wir auch die
maßnahmen gravierend genossen sondern
beziehen müssen wir über drei ebenen
reden ist eine ist sind die fach
gesetzlichen maßnahmen zu die ich jetzt
angesichts derzeit nicht sagen will und
wir werden natürlich im oster paket und
an vielen anderen stellen darüber reden
da werden wir auch unsere weiteren
vorschläge einbringen und dann habe das
personalproblem sie haben es ja kurz
erwähnt
natürlich wäre eine einstellung
offensive das richtige ich darf sie nur
darauf hinweisen dass wir auf einem vor
einem demografischen stehen und ein
drittel des öffentlichen dienstes uns in
diesem jahr 10 verlassen will woher sie
die leute haben wollen dass sie einen
aufwuchs im öffentlichen dienst
hinbekommen wollen das ist also ist
einfach unehrlich und deswegen müssen
wir lösungen für die lösungen liegen
ganz sicher in der automatisierung von
verfahren ich habe vorgestern an eine
sitzung des landkreistages teilgenommen
waren 300 kommunale vertreter die im
kern alle gesagt haben ihr versteht
überhaupt nicht wo wir unsere probleme
haben und da können sie natürlich auch
sagen dass natürlich auch die schuld
einer vorgängerregierung dass es nützt
uns ja alles nichts wir haben vor zwei
jahren das erkannt einen grundsätzlichen
neuanfang gefordert das steht auch in
unserem wahlprogramm haben eine rolle
als oppositions- kennst dich selber
umsetzen aber wir helfen der ampel neben
gerne unter anderem mit diesem antrag
aber keineswegs nur mit diesem antrag
dass wir da gemeinsam
als demokratie weiterkommen denn wenn
wir nicht weiterkommen dann werden wir
viele ziele nicht nur der klimapolitik
aber viele ziele eindeutig verfehlt und
ich würde gerne zu einem punkt noch
etwas sagen digitale verfahren heißt
nicht nur dass er plant offenlegung
machen dafür sind wir auch das haben wir
ja selber am klaren sieg gesagt wenn der
bund sich nicht entschließt die
standardisierung von verfahren selber in
die hand zu nehmen und diese
entscheidende weichenstellung haben sie
im koalitionsvertrag nicht getroffen und
ich habe große sorge dass sie das jetzt
während der ganzen legislaturperiode
nicht tun werden dann werden wir den
wildwuchs an digital verfahren in
kommunen und länder die gar nicht wissen
was sie beschaffen sollen weiter haben
mit der folge dass wir 40.000 verfahren
haben wir haben allein 328 verschiedene
verfahren die die einwohnermeldeämter in
deutschland wie die ihre daten sammeln
und abspeichern mit der folge dass wir
das nicht vernünftig konsolidiert
bekommen oder nur mit sehr großem
aufwand und wenn wir also diese
standardisierung nicht zu einem bundes
thema machen und wenn wir nicht alles
drei angehen sprich die fach
gesetzlichen verbesserungen die sie
vorschlagen bei denen wir welche in
unserem antrag vorlagen da gibt's
natürlich aus der gesellschaft noch
weitere wenn wir zweitens das thema
personal nicht angehen und
automatisierung von verfahren oder wir
drittens das thema standardisierung und
digitalisierung nicht so beginnen dass
wir der ernsthafte fortschritte machen
werden dann wird das was sie im
koalitionsvertrag sagen nämlich die
halbierung der planungsverfahren niemals
gelingen und roche hat heute morgen noch
gesagt sie wolle von sechs jahren auf
sechs monate runterkommen nicht dass wir
dagegen werden aber das wären wir glaube
ich auf gar keinen fall schaffen und
insofern nehmen sie das als angebot
diesen antrag für einen ernsthaften
dialog die wirklichen probleme man
ehrlich zu analysieren und gemeinsam zu
besprechen vielen dank
[Applaus]
für die spd-fraktion spricht nun die
kollegin dorothee matic und sich die
verkehrspolitische sprecherin der
fraktion
besten dank frau präsidentin meine damen
und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen das
thema planes beschleunigung das ist und
bleibt ein dauerbrenner und wetter
kollege heilmann sie haben eben gesagt
dass die sorge haben dass wir die ziele
im koalitionsvertrag der ampel nicht
erreichen und daher möchte ich jetzt
einen appell an sie richten dann sorgen
sie bitte als cdu csu fraktion auch in
ihrer verantwortung die sie in ländern
und kommunen tragen dafür dass auch dort
die umsetzung in der praxis wirklich
ankommt denn vor dem nächsten einfachen
wahrheit und ich bin auch davon
überzeugt das ist ein
gemeinschaftsprojekt
planungsbeschleunigungsgesetz
bestanden das geht nur im zusammenspiel
mit bund ländern und kommunen und da
haben sie auch eine verantwortung
unser klares ziel ist
hier werden die versorgung der
bürgerinnen und bürger mit und der
wirtschaft auch mit grünem strom wurde
schon viel gesagt mit digitaler
infrastruktur und auch nur zuverlässiger
verkehrsinfrastruktur zukunftsfähig
machen und das zu rasch wie möglich und
ja das heck sorgen hier
gestatten sie eine bemerkung oder frage
des kollegen
vielen dank dass sie die frage zu lassen
ja natürlich haben wir eine
verantwortung habe ist ihm bewusst dass
in bayern die 10h regel in den
vorranggebieten also den entscheidenden
gebieten gerade dabei ist ab geschaffen
zu werden haben sie zur kenntnis
genommen dass nordrhein westfalen das
bundesland ist mit den meisten wind
kräfte kraft weder die ans netz gegangen
sind im letzten jahr das ist einer der
gründe warum ist die wahl gewonnen hat
also jetzt tut sich noch nicht so als
wenn unsere länder gar nichts machen
würden da kann man sich natürlich jetzt
immer vorwerfen dies und das und jenes
aber
ich würde sagen wir sollten mal
gemeinsam anfangen und diesen dialog
aufnehmen dann haben sie das schon dass
eine opposition sagt wir reden ist auch
gerne gemeinsam mit ihm erstmal vielen
dank auch für das angebot ist nehmen wir
gerne an ich möchte ihnen aber auch aus
der praxis bei mir auch aus meinem
wahlkreis durchaus erzielen es ist
nämlich sehr oft wasser und wein was man
dort sieht wir haben ich komme aus
hamburg wissen sie vielleicht nicht wir
haben sehr ehrgeizige ziele auch im
wohnungsbau wochen schon viel erreicht
aber ich erlebe auch immer wieder und da
sind wir auch bei dem thema auch
kommunikation mit bürgerinnen bürgern
vor ort das auch von den cdu nicht
cdu/csu von cdu-seite dann auch wichtige
wohnungsbauvorhaben vor ort dann aus
oppositionellen gründen aus
opportunistischen gründen verhindert
werden und so kommen wir auch nicht
voran auch bei den wichtigen themen
wohnungsbau und das verfahren immer
weiter verzögert werden dass auch klagen
angestrengt werden das ist genau diese
verantwortung die ich meinen und die
nehmen sie vor ort ganz konkret nicht
wahr
liebe kollegen kollegen ich stehe an
erster stelle als verkehrspolitikerin
und als verkehrspolitikerin steht für
mich und steht für uns die schiene ganz
vorne und ja wir haben dort sehr
ambitionierte pläne im koalitionsvertrag
wir wollen bis 20.30 unter anderem die
verkehrsleistung auf der schiene
verdoppeln und auch den anteil des
schienengüterverkehrs deutlich steigern
denn nur wenn wir das angebot auf der
bahn verbessern werden mehr menschen die
züge nutzen und eben auch mehr güter auf
der schiene transportiert werden und
deswegen möchte ich auch ganz klar sagen
dass der deutschland takt und er auch
damit verbundene infrastrukturausbau
unerlässlich ist und ja auch dafür
brauchen wir wurde schon gesagt
einheitliche zulassungsverfahren
vermeidung von doppelprüfungen
standardisierte planfeststellung oder
auch früher stichtagsregelung um nur
einige punkte zu nennen und ich bin
davon überzeugt wir haben nicht nur das
jahrzehntes schienen neubaus vor uns
sondern eben auch das jahrzehnt der
sanierung und deswegen müssen wir auch
uns auch das baustellenmanagement
anschauen und müssen auch dort
strukturen und regelungen schaffen dass
eben auch sanierung auf einer
bahnstrecke zur gleichen zeit möglich
sind nicht eben mich glaubt viele von
uns kennen es einzelne stückelung von
bauabschnitten nacheinander also auch
hier müssen baumaßnahmen effizienter
schneller und auch vor allem
kundenfreundlicher zu ende gebracht
werden
aber es liegt auch neben dem anhält ganz
konkretes kleinere maßnahmen um eben
verschieden netzes zu verbessern darum
wird sich die beschleunigungs kommission
schiene kümmern die wir im
koalitionsvertrag
festgelegt haben und hier geht es darum
eben mehr kapazität im bahnangebot zu
erreichen vor allem auch für den
güterverkehr
da geht es auch darum bei der
elektrifizierung der schiene besser
voranzukommen etwa durch ein gezieltes
maßnahmenprogramm dafür und noch dort
mehr zu erreichen
und letztlich brauchen wir ja eine
beschleunigung für alle transformations-
vorhaben die wir uns vorgenommen haben
wir brauchen sie in allen bereichen der
verkehrsinfrastruktur und ja die bahn
als kern einer nachhaltigen mobilität
muss hier vorreiter sein wir brauchen
aber auch ein neues mindset hier in
deutschland in der gesellschaft in der
planung weg von einer manchmal
verhinderungs kultur die wir finden hin
zu einer kultur des ermöglichen vielen
dank
dorothee martin war das für die
spd-fraktion die verkehrspolitische
sprecherin
und sie hat noch einen weiteren teil was
die beschleunigungs und
genehmigungsverfahren
anbelangen die planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren und der
beschleunigung nämlich dass es auch eine
kommission bei der schiene geben sollte
das vorantreibt susanne menge jetzt für
die grün
reflektieren insbesondere übrigens aus
dem verkehrssektor
man könnte zb annehmen dass der zustand
unseres planeten und die jahr für jahr
tonnenweise
überschrittenen emissionswerte grund
genug sein könnten endlich
grundsätzlichen überzeugungen zu
revidieren bei der suche nach antworten
in ihrem antrag stoßen wir auf
circa 30 maßnahmen von denen einige
wirklich gut sind das möchte ich hier
betonen aber kollege heilmann sie haben
von verkrustung und komplexen aufgaben
gesprochen aber insbesondere die
verkrustung wird im verkehrssektor
deutlich denn dort werden wieder die
alten geister aus der flasche gelassen
die sie in verkehrspolitischen sektor so
oft betont haben mangels zeit nämlich
deshalb nur ein kleines beispiel sie
wollen nach dem gießkannenprinzip
straßen schienenstrecken und den
öffentlichen verkehr zitat gleichermaßen
voranbringen irgendwie also alles
fördern und im ergebnis viele neue
straßen bauen doch was wir angesichts
von klimakrise artensterben und einer
fragilen energieversorgung dringend
brauchen ist eine klare
schwerpunktsetzung in der
verkehrspolitik die energieeffizienten
flächensparende verkehrsmittel des
umweltverbundes müssen und das muss man
auch dann so betonen massiv gefördert
werden und auf diesen zweck müssen alle
maßnahmen zur planungs und
genehmigungsplanung endlich fokussiert
werden und ja das bleibt ein kraftakt in
dieser regierungskoalition das bleibt er
aber auch für alle politische und
zivilgesellschaftliche akteurinnen und
alle die längst klimaschutz soziale und
ökonomische verantwortung im
verkehrssektor zusammen denken und das
müssen wir in einen turbo tempo machen
weil die voraussetzungen dafür übrigens
nicht auf dem tisch lägen mit der
beschleunigungs kommission schiene macht
diese ampel koalition einen wichtigen
schritt in die richtige richtung und ich
hoffe dass sie alsbald ihre aufgabe auch
wahrnimmt dankeschön frist in
der die ankündigungen dazu gibt es
zumindest
susanne menge hat nochmal hier ihre
erwartungen geäußert
für die fdp spricht jetzt carina conrad
sie ist die stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende
der gal präsidentin liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen in der debatte ist doch
heute 1 überdeutlich geworden wir
brauchen einen turbo der planungs
beschleunigung und das überall wir
brauchen ihn bei aktuellen projekten nun
heute wird gezeigt an dem
gesetzesentwurf der heute abend
debattiert wird am lmg
beschleunigungsgesetz was möglich ist
wenn es notwendig ist und gerade weil
die herausforderungen unserer zeit
gerade so riesengroß sind wie sie sind
in allen bereichen müssen wir auch
planung neu denken weil die versäumnisse
so groß sind in den letzten jahren und
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von der
union ist es ja gut dass sie uns mal
aufgeschrieben haben was sie alles
hätten noch erledigen wollen wenn es
gegangen wären jetzt finden hier zur
schuldzuweisungen stadt wäre es denn
gewesen sein soll in den letzten jahr
ich sage immer 1 das hilft den menschen
da draußen überhaupt nicht an dieser
stelle die menschen da draußen ist es
völlig egal warum es nicht funktioniert
die menschen da draußen die interessiert
bis jetzt besser geht und darauf müssen
wir antworten geben und unser zustand
den wir vorgefunden haben gerade auch in
dem haus von volker wissing dem verkehrs
und digitalen ministerium der ist
erschreckend es ist erschreckend wenn
man sieht in welchem zustand unsere
infrastruktur ist die infrastruktur die
wir heute benutzen die bude von unseren
eltern von unseren großeltern von
unseren pur großeltern errichtet und
erschaffen und wir müssen hier einen
turbo einbringen zu erneuern zu
reparieren lücken zu schließen bei mir
zu hause sind lücken zu schließen in
rheinland pfalz von einer autobahn
darauf warten die menschen seit
jahrzehnten
da ist eine brücke zu bauen über den
rhein vorüber sind sich rheinkilometer
keine brücke darauf warten die menschen
seit jahrzehnten
infrastruktur muss geschaffen werden um
menschen zu verbinden wenn sie nicht
geschaffen er kostet das die menschen
lebenszeit es schadet der umwelt
vor dem comeback ich habe die uhr
angehalten starten sie eine bemerkung
oder frage des kollegen ulrich sehr gern
ulrich seine von der union nachdem sie
sich gerade über den zustand und den
ausbauzustand auch in ihrem bundesland
bei den autobahnen hier so ein bisschen
beschwert haben
initiativ bekannt dass die autobahnen
erst mit dem ersten januar 2021 auf den
bund übergegangen sind sie kennen
sicherlich aus der rechtsstaatspartei
den staatsaufbau die auftrags-
verwaltung und die zuständigkeit der
auftrags- verwaltung können sie mir
beantworten wer für die planung
der autobahnen in
rheinland pfalz in den letzten jahren
die verantwortung getragen hat geld war
genügend da nach dem investitions
hochlauf sie hätten es abgreifen können
diese frage bringt es auf den punkt will
welchen herausforderungen wir stehen und
es wurde eben schon vom kollegin martin
angesprochen es ist auch mit kultur
frage die wir uns in zukunft stellen
müssen schuldzuweisungen zu suchen warum
in der vergangenheit gingen nicht
funktioniert haben das kann man machen
sie haben geben die kollegen der linken
hier ganz außerordentlich beleidigt herr
kollege meine befürchtung ist dass wenn
der kulturwandel bei ihnen nicht an die
zu bild zu schauen und daran
mitzuarbeiten auf allen das fängt bei
den kommunen an das geht über die länder
bis hin zum bund dass man sich jeder an
jeder stelle die frage gestellt welchen
beitrag man selbst auch dazu leisten
kann dass sechs umfeld besser wird dann
prophezeie ich ihnen dass sie die
kontrolle der erfolge in der nächsten
legislaturperiode weiterhin aus der
opposition machen können aber
um noch mal auf den punkt zurück zu
kommen was alles passieren muss und was
wir vorgefunden haben die menschen in
nrw merken dass gerade an der rahmen der
talbrücke ganz enorm und hier ist auch
ein beispiel was diese ampel mit auf den
weg gebracht hat und auch unterstützt
und auch dafür meinen dank noch mal an
alle kolleginnen und kollegen dass wir
hier auch schneller werden nämlich wenn
infrastruktur gestört ist wenn
verkehrsader gestörtes beschäftigt dass
die menschen vor ort um dann müssen wir
auch schneller werden und wir brauchen
auch ein turbo bei der digitalisierung
und ohne zweifel da ist auch einiges
passiert in den letzten jahren aber
gerade die pandemie haben doch gezeigt
dass das lange nicht genug ist die
zukunft von der leistungsfähigen
digitalen infrastruktur ist kein
selbstzweck sondern ist voraussetzung
für eine moderne für eine
selbstbestimmte und für eine
wirtschaftlich starke gesellschaft und
dafür zu sorgen dass die flecken
geschlossen werden die jetzt noch
unterversorgt sind dass man auch in die
zukunft denkt was brauchen wir in
zukunft am datenstruktur das digitale
verwaltungen mitgedacht werden das ist
eine riesengroße aufgabe und die knoten
zu lösen die da alle gemacht wurden das
ist eine riesenaufgabe und sie können
sich sicher sein wir nehmen uns dieser
aufgabe an
es ist zeit für einen paradigmenwechsel
für einen kulturwechsel ich lade alle
dazu einer auch mitzumachen weil die
aufgabe so groß ist und es ist ganz klar
dass ermöglichen muss wieder vor dem
verhindern stehen geht nicht dafür habe
ich kein verständnis mehr warum alles
nicht möglich waren der vergangenheit
ist mir heute egal wir schauen ab heute
in die zukunft und verbessern die
situation
das ist unser ziel vielen dank
ja mit dem blick nach vorne carina
konrad von der
fdp fraktion
und die union die ja
den antrag hier eingebracht hat der die
grundlage dieser debatte ist spricht
jetzt geh tag konnte man
wo ein wille ist ist auch ein weg frau
präsidentin meine damen und herren
dieses sprichwort ist alt aber aktueller
denn je zu sehen an zwei großprojekten
direkt vor den toren berlins auf der
einen seite des planungs desaster willy
brandt flughafen
baukosten 7 statt eine milliarde euro
bauzeit 14 statt fünf jahren auf der
anderen seite das planungs vorbild mit
der giga factory von tesla team ehrgeiz
baukosten wie geplant bauzeit zwei jahre
das zauberwort
vorläufiger baubeginn ein unternehmer
der konnte eine politik die wollte wo
ein wille ist ist auch ein weg diese
ausnahme die wir erlebt haben muss aber
zur regel werden für alle großprojekte
in deutschland für erneuerbare jahr aber
eben auch für autobahn für breitband
privat oder staatlich denn spätestens
der krieg in der ukraine zeigt
deutschland ist nur so stark wie seine
eigene infrastruktur war deutschland ist
eben auch zu langsam zu kompliziert zu
bürokratisch
daran scheitern investition und projekte
ziehen sich hin wie unendliche
geschichten ich nenne nur stichworte wie
stuttgart21
vertiefung hamburg fehmarn belt querung
friesenbrücke
rheinbrücke leverkusen die liste ließe
sich endlos fortsetzen
alle diese projekte ein das
planungsrecht begünstigt derzeit nicht
schnelles bauen sondern eher leichter
blog haben und verteuerte projekte und
um klagen abzuwehren ist häufig der
modernen ablasshandel zurückgekehrt die
bevölkerung schüttelt inzwischen nur
noch den kopf sie verlieren den glauben
an die lösungs fähigkeit der politik
denn wir haben kein erkenntnisproblem
sondern ein umsetzungsproblem
beispiel gefällig die a20 in
schleswig holstein seit 1960 geplant
abschluss wahrscheinlich 2030 in
mecklenburg vorpommern in sieben jahren
umgesetzt möglich machte es das
investitionsmaßnahmen gesetz von helmut
kohl der gesetzgeber trat an die stelle
der planfeststellungsbehörde es geht
also wenn man will keine frage dieses
thema gab es schon zu zeiten der broker
es gab keine einheit wieder hier im
bundestag noch mit dem bundesrat nur in
zeiten des krieges von versorgungslücken
lieferengpässen im zeichen der rezession
und hohe inflation können wir uns dies
nicht mehr erlauben wir brauchen dieses
gemeinschaftsprojekt in diesem haus mit
den ländern mit den kommunen wohligen
connemann gestatten sie eine frau bei
oder bemerkung der kollegin männer ja
natürlich sehr gerne
tun frau connemann das haben sie gerade
aufgelistet was ich mit den alten
geistern der verkehrspolitik meinte sie
haben haufenweise autobahn 3 aufgelistet
die nicht nur umweltpolitisch hart
umstritten sind sondern wo es auch noch
ganz andere probleme gibt was den
baulichen untergrund betrifft halten sie
es wirklich in der jetzigen situation
für angemessen was den
ressourcenverbrauch betrifft und auch
was die flächen den flächenverbrauch
betrifft was die vernichtung von mooren
betrifft in dieser form diese
autobahnprojekte noch einzufordern
ich habe im wesentlichen unter anderem
von einer autobahnbrücke gesprochen die
dazu führt dass ein schwerlast verkehrt
seit mehr als vier jahren über
riesen umwege geführt werden muss
übrigens mit entsprechender belastung
der umwelt durch co2-emissionen der
staus vorprogrammiert der ein gesamtes
verkehrsnetz überfordert und wollen sie
das wirklich gut heißen unsere antwort
lautet an dieser stelle nein wir
brauchen eine beschleunigung um auch
solche projekte schneller abschließen zu
können zudem wohl nicht nur der
bevölkerung sondern auch zum wohl von
klima- umwelt- und nur weil es ihnen
nicht passt können sie das nicht
ausblenden
und deswegen
unterstützen wir ja auch die planungs
beschleunigungs für alan joyce aber
gleichzeitig verschiebt die ampel das
ziel für den gigabit ausbau bremst
insoweit den ausbau des netzes aber wir
brauchen die planungs beschleunigung für
leitungs trassen für beantragten
schifffahrtswegen und eben die autobahn
wir haben dazu vorschläge gemacht sie
machen sich darüber lustig aber wenn wir
es gemeinsam schaffen wollen brauchen
wir eben
planungsverfahren die wir per gesetz
durchführen können maßnahmen gesetze die
aussetzung der pflicht der zur
umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung für manche
großprojekte damit werden übrigens nicht
umweltschutz belange ausgesetzt sie
werden wichtig aber die verfahren wären
nicht endgültig unendlich verzögert und
wir brauchen gesetzliche
stichtagsregelung mit standard fristen
für einsprüche wenn eine behörde nicht
reagiert muss man also nicht bis zum
sankt nimmerleinstag warten und die
salamitaktik bei einwänden in
planungsverfahren muss beendet werden
das geht durch entsprechend die
wiedereinführung der materiellen
präzision es gibt viele vorschläge die
wir gemacht haben dem grunde nach geht
es aber um eine kernfrage nämlich die
frage ob wir bereit sind gemeinsam einen
mentalitätswechsel durchzuführen und das
ist der mentalitätswechsel zu sagen wo
ein wille ist ist auch ein gehweg wir
als cdu csu bundestagsfraktion wollen
diesen weg gehen vielen dank und
fordern unter anderem eine verbindliche
höchstdauer von genehmigungsverfahren
allerdings ist es so dass ist es nicht
so dass es das besagen nicht gäbe bei
windenergieprojekten beispielsweise gibt
es da eine vorschrift im
bundesemissionsschutzgesetz für
genehmigungs fristen zwischen drei und
sieben monaten die regelmäßig bei weitem
überschritten werden
kollegen ich muss ganz kurz ein paar
sachen klarstellen die die vorrednerin
hier erwähnt hat die ampel hat nicht
beschlossen den gigabit ausbau zu
verschieben da können sie sich relativ
sicher sein
ich würde da worte noch einmal
aufgreifen und sie können sich sicher
sein wir haben den willen und wir werden
auch den richtigen weg finden an dieser
stelle muss ich aber sagen dass der weg
ihres antrags heute noch nicht
ausgereift ist der kollege mansouri ist
auf viele punkte dieses antrags
eingegangen ich möchte mir einen kleinen
bereich noch mal heraus greifen die
schreiben in ihrem antrag sie wollen die
digitalisierung in allen lebensbereichen
und das wollen sie erreichen mit mehr
tempo bei planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren und liebe
kolleginnen liebe kollegen in dieser
kausalkette gebe ich ihnen vollkommen
recht wir erinnern uns sie wollen
digitalisierung in allen lebensbereichen
dann greifen die drei konkrete maßnahmen
auf sie wollen digitale einreichung von
planungsunterlagen sie wollen eine
digitalisierung im bauwesen und sie
wollen die digitalisierung von akten und
urkunden
liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen ich
weiß nicht wie viele lebensbereiche sie
kennen mit akten urkunden und dem
bauwesen ist es im regelfall nicht getan
sie vergessen an dieser stelle
wesentliche zusammenhänge und ich habe
ihren antrag etliche male gelesen ich
habe kein einziges mal das wort
breitbandausbau gefunden sie schreiben
nichts zu planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren um den
breitbandausbau zu beschleunigen und wir
können tatsächlich und das können wir
gerne machen weil es wichtig und richtig
ist über die digitalisierung im bauwesen
sprechen ich stelle mir nur die frage
wie unternehmen wie bürgerinnen und
bürger und die unsere verwaltung mit
einem immer größeren datenaufkommen zu
recht kommen soll wenn wir nicht die
notwendigen datenverbindungen dafür
schaffen
sie vergessen diese kompletten
zusammenhänge aber das ist an dieser
stelle tatsächlich auch okay wir
vergessen sie nämlich nicht die ampel
wird tempo machen beim breitbandausbau
die ampel wird tempo machen beim bau von
mobilfunk einrichtungen und die ampel
wird tempo machen bei planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren darauf hat sich
diese fortschritts koalition verständigt
und olaf scholz hat es versprochen als
der kanzler am 15.12 von einem
umfangreichen paket im ersten jahr
gesprochen hat hat der kanzler vor etwa
einem halben jahr die digitalisierung
mitgedacht liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen von der union sechs monate
später leider nicht wir leben in den
antrag an dieser stelle ab
[Applaus]
letzter redner in dieser debatte ist der
kollege jürgen berghahn aus der spd vor
zu
vielen dank frau präsidentin liebe
kollegin kollegen in meiner ersten
bundestagsrede vor ziemlich genau zwei
monaten habe ich zu diesem thema
planungs beschleunigung und genehmigungs
beschleunigung schon gesprochen die
cdu/csu bietet mir heute in ihrem antrag
also freundlicherweise noch mal die
gelegenheit auf die in dieser zeit schon
erfolgten fortschritte einzugehen der
vorliegende antrag betont die
wichtigkeit erneuerbare energien und der
klimaneutralität das ist natürlich
völlig richtig wobei es mich irritiert
dass die cdu und csu diese themen erst
jetzt für sich entdeckt hat
den regierungsparteien ist die
wichtigkeit da schon länger bekannt
weshalb wir zb das poster paket so
schnell auf den weg gebracht haben
mit diesem setzen wir etliche
energiepolitische inhalte des
koalitionsvertrags zügig um
unter anderem gehen wir den
beschleunigten ausbau erneuerbaren
entgegen an das bundes bedarf plan
gesetzt oder das
energiewirtschaftsgesetz wird angegangen
um nur ein paar zu nennen
wir verringern in zahlreichen bereichen
bürokratische hürden verschlanken
erforderliche verfahren sprich diese
koalition bringt tempo in die planungs
und genehmigungsverfahren
aber wenn sie tatsächlich uns
unterstützen wollen dann wirken sie doch
bitte auf ihre kolleginnen kollegen der
cdu und csu in der europäischen union
ein denn dort wird gerade in der eu
kommission das thema planungs
beschleunigung aus gebremst da können
sie tatsächlich unterstützen als
weiteren punkt betont der antrag die
relevanz intakter moderner verkehrswege
und fordert eine verstärkte
digitalisierung auch das ist völlig
korrekt die ampel konzentriert sich auf
die sanierung und stand setzungen
bestehende verkehrswege und da wo nötig
den ausbau notwendiger straßen
standardisierte verfahren sind ebenfalls
geplant beispielsweise beim bau von
brücken und auch der einsatz von
building information modeling sowie eine
frühzeitige bürgerbeteiligung sind
selbstverständlich vorgesehen in
lüdenscheid an der baustelle rammelt
saarbrücken gibt es zum beispiel an
bürger band drauf aber auftrag hat
schnittstelle zur bevölkerung wirtschaft
und politik ist direkt angebunden an das
bundesministerium an die staatssekretäre
wir verabschieden also nicht nur papiere
sondern wir setzen auch die inhalte um
für den herbst sind wie sie alle wissen
weitere maßnahmenpakete geplant um die
planung verfahren genehmigungen in
zusätzlichen bereichen zu beschleunigen
liebe kollegen kollegen der cdu csu wenn
ich mir ihren antrag so durchlese habe
ich den eindruck dass sie in den letzten
wochen vielleicht ein bisschen im urlaub
waren sie fordern hier dinge die die
ampel längst beschlossen und teilweise
sogar schon umgesetzt hatte lesen sie
doch zum beispiel beim punkt 9 punkte
plan des
bundesverkehrsministeriums oder dem
sogenannten
ruster paket nach dann werden sie
feststellen dass ihr antrag überflüssig
ist und ganz offensichtlich auf ihre
versäumnisse der letzten 16 jahre
hinweist vielen dank
so jürgen berghahn für die spd der
letzte redner gibt es hören wir mal die
bundestags-vizepräsidentin petra pau wie
die mit dem antrag der union weiter
verfahren wird wir kommen zur abstimmung
über den antrag der fraktionen der
cdu/csu auf drucksache
1854 mit dem titel planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren weiter
beschleunigen für wohlstand
versorgungssicherheit und ökologischen
mehrwert wer stimmt für diesen antrag
die cdu/csu-fraktion wer stimmt dagegen
die
koalitionsfraktionen die fdp fraktion
und die fraktion die linke wer enthält
sich
niemand der antrag ist damit abgewählt
ja und das ziemlich deutlich aber das
hatte sich in der debatte ja schon
angekündigt ja planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren dauern in
deutschland das ohne frage viel zu lange
ob beim wohnungsbau bei
verkehrsprojekten oder bei der
errichtung von windparks beispielsweise
viele beispiele haben wir ja auch
während der debatte gehört die politik
hat das erkannt dass auch fortschritte
beispielsweise was die erreichung der
klimaziele anbelangt nur zu machen ist
wenn es eben mehr tempo gibt die
regierungskoalition hat sich das schon
in den koalitionsvertrag
hineingeschrieben
aber das wird sicher ein
weiteres thema seien für die nächsten
monate urlaub scholz hat angekündigt
noch in diesem jahr werde die
bundesregierung dazu nötigen
entscheidungen treffen um die zeit der
planungs und genehmigungsverfahren halb
zu halbieren der antrag der union wie
gesagt der ist ja sie erst mal abgelehnt
aber das thema das bleibt natürlich
aktuell so jetzt kommen wir zu einem
weiteren tagesordnungspunkt an diesem
donnerstag hier im bundestag viele
unternehmen und auch bürger haben
finanziell ja weiter auch mit der korona
krise zu kämpfen
schon während der
koalitionsverhandlungen hat die ampel
beschlossen dass viele hilfen verlängert
werden heute passiert das jetzt mit der
abschließenden lesung des vierten
coroner steuer hilfe gesetzes da fällt
eine ganze menge darunter die home
office pauschale wird es auch für 2022
geben beispielsweise unternehmen dürfen
verluste besser verrechnen wir hören
dazu eine menge in der aussprache so
viel wird sicher sein markus herbrand
für die fdp der erste redner
heute geht es etwas harmonisch dazu das
liegt mir auch persönlich ehrlich gesagt
vielmehr mit dem corolla sparer hilfe
gesetz vier sätzen wir nämlich eine
ganze reihe von maßnahmen um
entlastungsmaßnahmen die auf der einen
seite sehr sozial ausgewogen aber auch
wirtschaftlich wirklich sehr sinnvoll
sind schon die korona steuergesetze 1
bis 3 die die vorgängerregierung auf den
weg gebracht hat wurde durch große teile
der opposition auch immer unterstützt
wenn ich jetzt mal von der temporären
umsatz steuersenkung ab siehe die wir
immer sehr kritisch gesehen haben haben
wir diese corona steuer hilfe gesetzt 1
bis 3 auch immer sehr
optimistisch unterstützt zum gesetz
selber will ich sagen es sind eine ganze
reihe von maßnahmen die schon im gesetz
standen auf der anderen seite aber auch
im gesetzgebungsverfahren durch die
ampel noch mal deutlich erweitert wurden
wir führen ein als die
steuerfreistellung für einen corona
bonus pflegekräfte im
gesetzgebungsverfahren haben wir diesen
personenkreis noch einmal deutlich
ausgeweitet und wir sind uns der sache
bewusst das ist sehr schwierig in der
abgrenzung und wir haben uns da sehr
stark daran gehalten was im
infektionsschutzgesetz an personen
gruppen aufgelistet ist das ist eine
gute lösung und wir haben den
personenkreis wo noch mal deutlich
erweitern können
darüber hinaus darüber hinaus verlängern
wir die steuerfreiheit für das
kurzarbeitergeld um weitere drei monate
und werden sehen müssen ob das
ausreichend ist wir verlängern auch die
home office pauschale bis zum 31.12 und
ja wir sind uns auch darüber einig in
der ampel da muss noch etwas mehr
geschehen wir waren wir haben den
experten das sehr sorgfältig auch
zugehört wir glauben wir brauchen da
eine etwas strukturelle lösung und
werden das in kurt in kürze angehen
zunächst einmal jetzt hier die
verlängerung bis zum 31
zwölften damit wir die
lebenswirklichkeit vieler menschen die
arbeitswirklichkeit vieler menschen
besser abbilden können wir haben die
idee dass die abschreibung noch mal
verlängert ein weiteres jahr ein ganz
wichtiger investitionsanreiz für vor
allem kleine und mittelständische
unternehmen und wir verlängern die rede
die investitions fristen für rücklagen
nach dem paragrafen 6b und 7 g im
einkommensteuergesetz das ist ganz
wichtig für unternehmen die
möglicherweise jetzt nicht die
liquidität haben um diese rücklagen
auflösen oder in anspruch nehmen zu
können weil einfach jetzt krise war
deshalb kommt diese verlängerung genau
richtig und wir
packen noch mal den verlust die
verlustverrechnung an wir verlängern die
verlustverrechnung noch mal bis zum
31.12.2013 und 20 führen also die
erhöhten verlust für rechnungsbeträge
zurück erst im veranlagungszeitraum
2024 und wir implementieren diesem
verlust rück trag dauerhaft auf zwei
jahren ja
das ist auch in der ampel durchaus
strittig gewesen das müsste man sagen
wir haben darüber länger diskutiert und
einige hätten sich mehr
vorstellen können letzten endes ist auf
diesen kompromiss hinausgelaufen den wir
selbstverständlich auch mittragen und
wir sind auch noch mal an die fristen
für die steuerberatenden berufe rahmen
herangegangen und da sogar über die
vorstellung des bundesrates hinaus weil
die dass ein berufsstand ist der
wirklich mit ganz enormen belastungen in
dieser corona pandemie zu kämpfen hat
die korona hilfen 14 müssen abgerechnet
werden jetzt kommen in zukunft auch noch
die die grundsteuer belastung dazu
deshalb machen wir es möglich dass die
fristen da auch dauerhaft verlängert
werden und wir sorgen für
planungssicherheit planungssicherheit
das ist zurückgeführt wird dass diese
dauerhaften fristverlängerungen
zurückgeführt werden damit wir möglichst
20 25 wieder beim normalzustand
angelangt sind das ist
planungssicherheit für diese büros und
letzten endes vor allem für die
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter in
und schließlich schaffen wir die
bilanzielle abzinsung von
unverzinslichen verbindlichkeiten ab
eine regelung her ist aus meiner sicht
die bedurft hätte und sowieso keine
große rolle spielt im steuerrecht es ist
sozusagen eine kleine hygiene maßnahmen
im steuerrecht die wir an dieses gesetz
noch angekurbelt haben meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich bedanke
mich für die tolle zusammenarbeit in den
vielen gesprächen die wir in diesem zu
diesem gesetz geführt haben auch mit der
opposition in der tat ein wirklich gutes
und gelungenes gesetz ich bitte um
zustimmung herzlichen dank
sagt markus herbrand für die
fdp-fraktion
und heute ist nämlich zweite und dritte
lesung und entsprechend daneben auch die
abstimmung im anschluss an diese debatte
fritz güntzler jetzt für die union frau
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen meine damen und herren
insbesondere auf den zuschauerrängen sie
dir nehmen harmonie war herr kollege
hermann hat dass er ein gefordert und
ich kann vorab schon sagen das wusste er
auch nach den beratungen im ausschuss
dass wir diesen corona steuergesetz hier
zustimmen werden weil wir diese steuer
hilfe gesetz vier natürlich auch in
einer gewissen tradition der letzten
drei kroner steuer hilfe gesetze sehen
die wir in der großen koalition noch
gemeinsam meist auch mit der zustimmung
der fdp
beschlossen haben es sind im
wesentlichen die gleichen maßnahmen die
dort enthalten sind die jetzt entfristet
werden oder fortgeschrieben werden wir
bedauern aber um ein bisschen wasser in
den wein zu gießen dass es ein wenig
spät gekommen ist also der
regierungsentwurf war erst im februar 22
muss jetzt sehen dinge die dieses jahr
komplett gelten soll werden im bundesrat
im juni beschlossen also ein halbes jahr
ist vorbei bevor die maßnahmen
tatsächlich beschlossen wurden und sie
haben von hinten von rechts sicherheit
gesprochen die geschaffen werden soll
ist das etwas schwierig wenn der
beschluss im bundesrat am 10 juni 2022
die erste erfolg im ergebnis habe ich
gesagt stimmen wir zu aber im ergebnis
hätte noch ein wenig mehr sein können
sie gehen in den richtigen weg den
richtigen weg sind aber leider auf
halber strecke wie so oft stehen
geblieben und wir hatten ihnen es so
leicht gemacht wir haben einen
entschließungsantrag eingebracht mit 14
punkten herr kollege hermann die ihn
nicht ganz unbekannt vorkommen dürften
die sie hätten übernehmen können aber
leider werden sie ja wohl gemeinsam
heute als ampelkoalition wie schon im
ausschuss diesen antrag ablehnen unser
ziel ist gemeinsam wir wollen
wirtschaftliche folgen der korona krise
aber auch der es um kleine krise
abfedern und so dazu beitragen dass es
stabilisierung bei den unternehmen gibt
aber auch entlastungen bei
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmern und
es geht auch darum die eigenkapitalbasis
von unternehmen wieder zu stärken die in
der schwierigen zeit ihr eigenkapital
abschmelzen mussten das unglück da war
und dazu geführt hat dass sie in der
krise bestand hatten was aber fehlt um
das ganze vielleicht ein wenig weiter
auch in richtung vorgeformt projekt zu
bringen ich will ja gar nicht das böse
wort unternehmenssteuerreform im mund
nehmen wäre doch einiges mehr notwendig
gewesen und ist ja schon spannend zu
sehen wenn man die mitteilung vom
bundesfinanzminister lindner ließ in
seiner broschüre finanzpolitik in der
zeitenwende und er davon spricht dass
wir ein wettbewerbsfähiges steuerrecht
brauchen und auch davon spricht dass die
belastung der kapitalgesellschaften in
deutschland zu hoch ist hat er recht
aber wo sie bleiben die vorschläge
fraglich nur in richtung
bundesfinanzminister lindner und die
staatssekretärin ist ja da die kann das
ja dann mitnehmen also würden schon
erwarten dass man nicht nur papiere
schreibt sondern dass man auch handeln
und dinge hier ins parlament einbringen
und sie haben natürlich wichtige dinge
angesprochen adressiert in diesem cola
steuer hilfe gesetz und ich glaube ein
punkt ist die liquidität in den
unternehmen zu stärken weil liquidität
ist mit das wichtigste und darum
verstehen wir es gut dass sie die
verlustverrechnung den verlust
rückschlag auf zwei jahre verlängert
haben aber ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
dagegen noch mehr ich weiß auch dass wir
diese diskussion in der großen koalition
in der vergangenheit geführt haben und
ich weiß auch in richtung grüne und fdp
wie schwer es mit diesem
koalitionspartner über
verlustverrechnung zu reden weil das
problem der sozialdemokratie in
deutschland ist anscheinend dass sie
mein verlustverrechnung wer ein
steuergeschenk und da muss man dass wir
diese fragen da ihre zieht komplett weil
gast in latente steuern die
qualitätsansprüche steuer
erstattungsansprüche von unternehmen die
sie wieder bekommen wenn sie mal
verluste gemacht haben und dann wieder
gewinne gemacht haben oder in der
vergangenheit gewinne gemacht haben
bekommen sie ihr geld nur wieder und sie
würden in dieser situation weil hat
besseren verlustverrechnung ihr geld
schneller wieder bekommen von daher wäre
es begrüssenswert gewesen den rückkauf
drei jahre auszuweiten oder sogar vier
jahre auszuweiten wenn ich das hier als
hinweis der grünen aufnehmen nach weil
jetzt der zweijährige verlust rückt der
zum glück dauerhaft kommen aber in die
verlustjahre 20 21 und 20 22 geht also
von daher passt das nicht ganz auch über
die höhe haben wir schon viel gestritten
ich glaube dass es auch unzureichend es
sich unbedingt zu erklären warum größere
unternehmen ihre verluste nicht
verrechnen dürfen werden kleinere
unternehmen bis zehn millionen das
verrechnen können und ein weiterer punkt
ist die der verlustvortrag ich verstehe
gar nicht um das thema überhaupt nicht
aufgegriffen worden ist es ist ja so in
deutschland wenn sie verluste gemacht
haben können sie in der gewinne der
zukunft nur teilweise verrechnen und das
ist eigentlich das richtige unternehmen
die aus der krise herauskommen die dann
wieder gewinne macht dass man denen dann
die möglichkeit gibt das vollständig mit
den verlusten der vergangenheit zu
verrechnen das wäre glaube ich das
richtige signal gewesen
des weiteren geht es ums thema
abschreibungen herr kollege herr brandt
hat herausgestellten das wären heute
läuft die degressive abschreibung ist
entrüstet worden aber warum mussten sie
den fristen weil die super
abschreibungen die sie ihrem
koalitionsvertrag den menschen in diesem
land versprochen haben für das jahr 2022
und 20 23 bis jetzt nur auf dem papier
da ist es gibt keinen wurf es gibt keine
idee es gibt nur zwei zeilen im
koalitionsvertrag und da muss ich sagen
mit verlaub das ist ein bisschen wenig
und dann müssen sie sich nicht loben
lassen für die degressive abschreibung
und wenn wir es dann sinnvoll solche
verbesserungen von
abschreibungsbedingungen nicht mitten im
jahr zu beschließen sondern rechtzeitig
im vorlauf zu beschließen weil
investitionszyklen bei unternehmen
dauern länger also von daher wäre es
richtiger gewesen dann auch das jahr
2023 mitzunehmen weil sie glauben ja
selber nicht mehr daran dass ihre super
abschreibung 20 23 kommen wird also von
daher ein bisschen wehmut wer hier nicht
nur mehr mut zu fortschritten mehr mut
zu vernünftiger steuerpolitik wer hier
gut gewesen und
weitere dinge fehlen ich will nur das
thema ansprechen verluste in der
situation die jetzt entstehen
unternehmen die beteiligung in russland
haben das thema ist überhaupt nicht
adressiert sie haben's thema überhaupt
nicht aufgenommen das bedaure ich sehr
weil da gibt es erhebliche probleme
durch die sanktionen durch enteignung
durch zerstörungen haben deutsche
unternehmen die beteiligung halten in
russland erhebliche probleme da wäre
auch mehr gewesen abfließen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich habe es
gesagt wir stimmt zu da war mehr luft
nach oben schade dass sie keine unserer
weiß richten denn vorschläge aus dem
entschließungsantrag übernommen haben
aber sie werden ja die möglichkeit haben
das im weiteren gesetzgebungsverfahren
zu tun und dann werden sie das als ihren
eigenen erfolg verbuchen aber ich werde
immer darauf hinweisen dass wir das
schon vorher geforderten herzlichen dank
künstler war es für die unionsfraktion
also einige punkte hier am gesetzentwurf
der ampel da hat er sich daran
abgearbeitet die union hat einen eigenen
antrag vorgelegt und fordert unter
anderem dass der gesamte
einkommenssteuertarif an die unerwartet
hohe inflation angepasst werden sollen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen meine
damen und herren der künstler wenn sie
uns immer so kritisieren aber am ende
dann doch zustimmen freut uns ist in der
tat sehr dass
keine noch was werden mit uns genau das
vierte corinna steuer hilfe gesetz ist
eine zentrale und wichtige maßnahme um
etwas zu bewegen für arbeitnehmerinnen
und arbeitnehmer in unserem land für das
thema arbeit und für die unterstützung
von kleinen und mittleren unternehmen in
einem durchaus sehr angespannten
wirtschaftlichen umfeld ein gutes werk
ist im rahmen unserer gemeinsamen
verhandlungen und beratungen noch besser
geworden unser gesetz steht in einer
guten tradition es wurde schon gesagt
bisheriger coroner gesetze nicht nur
wegen des konsenses sondern weil wir
hier erneut zu schnell greifende
maßnahmen zur hilfe und entlastung
kommen dort wo die folgen der pandemie
besonders spürbar sind in besonderer
weise gilt es natürlich für die
beschäftigten im gesundheitswesen und in
der pflege die von uns vorgelegte steuer
und auch abgabenfreiheit für die
ko-runde sonderzahlung ist eine logische
konsequenz und zugleich wichtige
ergänzung des pflege bonus gesetzes bei
angestellten den krankenhäusern und in
der langzeitpflege in ambulanten und
stationären einrichtungen tätig sind wir
wollen mit der ermöglichung von
steuerfreien corona boni für eine
finanzielle wertschätzung insbesondere
der arbeit bei den beschäftigten sorgen
die viele überstunden zu bewältigung
dieser pandemie auf sich genommen haben
die erheblichen mentalen belastungen
ausgesetzt waren und natürlich auch
direkten
gesundheitsgefahren und stichwort halbe
strecke weil es unter anderem in der
öffentlichen anhörung auch weitergehende
forderungen gab weitere berufsgruppen
rhein zu nehmen will ich noch mal
ausdrücklich sagen es ist aus unserer
sicht absolut vertretbar und gut dort zu
helfen wo die folgen der pandemie mit am
stärksten ausgeprägt waren und das sind
die bereiche gesundheit und pflege und
dazu stehen wir liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
es ist dann ein schöner erfolg der
verhandlungen und berichterstatter
gespräche dass wir jetzt ampel den
adressatenkreis für den steuerfreien
corona bonus erhöht haben in dem jetzt
analog zum bundesrat die tarifverträge
mit reinnehmen die freiwilligen zahlung
und auch aufstockung durch die
arbeitgeber und es wurde ja schon von
den herbrand genannt weitere
einrichtungen gemäß des
infektionsschutzgesetzes arztpraxen
dialyse reha und ambulantes operieren
das bedeutet auf den punkt gebracht bis
zu eine million beschäftigte mehr
nämlich 870.000 medizinische
fachangestellte und 86.000
rettungssanitäterin rettungssanitäter
können zusätzlich von unserem gesetz
profitieren und wir sind uns auch sicher
dass die arbeitgeber von dieser
möglichkeit rege gebrauch machen werden
das ist ein ganz wichtiges signal in die
gesellschaft hinein und echter
fortschritt durch eine fortschritts
koalition liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wichtig für die stützung der konjunktur
in der aktuellen lage und für die
liquidität und investitionsfähigkeit
gerade von kleinen und mittleren
unternehmen sind die maßnahmen die wir
auf den weg bringen die degressive
abschreibung die durch den
koalitionsvertrag so vorgesehen war aber
jetzt natürlich auch sehr notwendig ist
im vorgriff auf die sich in konzeption
befindliche
investitionspläne die verlängerung der
investitions fristen für reinvestitionen
und die verlängerung der erweiterten
verlustrechnung und vor allem die jetzt
neu auf dauer angelegte möglichkeit des
verlusts zurück trages auf zwei jahre
das ist eine wirkliche weiterentwicklung
unseres steuerrechts wir bewegen uns
damit auch in der internationalen
dynamik von steuerpolitischen maßnahmen
für unternehmen
das ist gut für unsere volkswirtschaft
und das ist auch gut für den standort
deutschland die wir kolleginnen und
kollegen
was bleibt ist die botschaft die ampel
koalition handelt in ungemütlichen
zeiten wir helfen beschäftigten im
gesundheitswesen in der pflege wir
helfen den mittelstand und bringen das
thema arbeit voran in diesem sinne
werden wir aus überzeugung dem vierten
pur ohne steuer hilfe gesetz zustimmen
ohne so schön dass es auch andere grenzt
vielen dank
[Applaus]
das wort hat der abgeordnete albrecht
glaser für die augen
[Applaus]
präsidentin meine damen und herren der
gesetzentwurf zielt darauf ab das
steuerrecht als wichtiges instrument zur
stabilisierung stärkung der konjunktur
einzusetzen wie es in der begründung
heißt um die wirtschaftlichen folgen der
pandemie abzumildern die vorredner haben
die einzelmaßnahmen bereits aufgezählten
christi wasserverlust rückt steuer
fahrrad ist fähige wohnungszählung zum
office pauschale und viele andere dinge
mehr die gleiche richtung zielt ein
änderungsantrag der cdu csu fraktion mit
zahlreichen forderungen die in den
letzten zwei jahren schon mehrfach von
der fdp-fraktion im bundestag beantragt
wurden bis 20 20 20 wie in diesem hause
üblich auch von der cdu wurden die alle
reflex schafft abgelehnt in dieser zeit
politische agonie fällt auch die
unsinnige wiederbelebung der grundsteuer
das war steuerliche denkmalspflege das
gegenteil vom fortschritt in diesen
tagen bekommen die eigentümer von 35
millionen grundstücken papierberge um
ihre immobilien werte zu ermitteln
eine drehende von unserem zusatzpunkt 1
beantragte fristverlängerung für die
bewältigung dieses bürokratiemonster das
ist teil geboten bereits in der
kirchhoffs in kirchhofs echter
steuerreform von vor zehn jahren kommt
die grundsteuer nicht mehr vor und in
jedem kopf eines steuerreform es kommt
sie auch nicht mehr vor in der
begründung ist sie die ohren das heißt
es weiter dass die anhaltend hohe
inflation das niedrige
wirtschaftswachstum anzeichen einer
stagnation sein könnten meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren das ist in
der tat stand der erkenntnis die
inflationsrate lag im april dieses
jahres bei 7,4
energiekosten sind um 35 im
jahresvergleich gestiegen erdgas hat mit
47,5 zum preisschock beigetragen mit
98,6 das gespenst der inflation in der
eu kommt also mit macht was zu erwarten
war jahrelang wurde uns erzählt dass die
inflation besiegt sei dann war die
inflation von unter aber nahe 2 eine
neue preisstabilität eine eigene
definition des hauses ezb als ich die
inflationsrate in nur 2 prozent linie
bewegte wurde das narrativ des
symmetrischen
inflationsziels bemüht um auch diesen
vorgang irgendwie weg zu leben die ezb
verlautbaren in diesen tagen zieht ihre
wir glauben dass die inflation im laufe
dieses jahres zurückgehen und im
nächsten und übernächsten jahr viel
niedriger sein wird wie in diesem jahr
zitat ende
wie kann man sich dieses ausmaß an
realitätsverweigerung erklären gerade
hat die us-notenbank die zinsen zur
inflationsbekämpfung erhöhen müssen die
ezb betreibt stattdessen auftragsarbeit
für den club med der romanischen staaten
der seit jahren den ezb-rat beherrscht
von unabhängigkeit der ezb keine spur
von lagarde ist und war französische
politikerin meine damen und herren von
wirtschaft versteht sie nebenbei bemerkt
auch nicht
das einzige interesse dieser mehrheit
und präsidentin ist die überschuldeten
romanischen länder vor staatskosten zu
bewahren werden die euro zinsen
angehoben steigen die kosten für die
staatsschulden bleibt die inflation oder
wird sie größer schmelzen die
staatsschulden das ist die handlungs
leitende maxime von lagarde und ihrem
klub in deutschland beim gouverneur hat
dort keine chancen wohl deshalb hat er
resigniert seinen hut genommen wie zwei
deutsche chefvolkswirte ebenfalls kurz
vorher
der bestand an zehn tagen meine damen
und herren hat sich seit 2008 bis ende
letzten jahres von 880 milliarden auf 6
millionen erhöht das ist eine für sieben
fassung der geldmenge in der gleichen
zeit ist das bip in der eurozone um 32
prozent gestiegen dh der geldmenge von
600 prozent erhöhung steht eine
inflation entsteht ein
wirtschaftswachstum von 32 gegenüber ein
vorgang der bei der wirklich
unabhängigen bundesbank unvorstellbar
wäre die finanzierung des
staatshaushaltes durch die notenpresse
und abgekoppelt von der realen
produktion hat in der geschichte der
menschheit immer zu staatswesen geführt
die null negativ
zinspolitik verstärkt seit jahren den
effekt dieser ahnungslosen
schuldenpolitik die ezb die
staatsschulden exzesse der
mitgliedstaaten größtenteils
mitfinanziert und dadurch erst
ermöglicht die staatsschulden der
euro-länder sind seine finanzkrise von
6,7 billionen auf 11,3 millionen
angewachsen mehr als 200 mal wurden
dabei die stabilitätskriterien gerissen
natürlich ohne sensoren von diesem
schuldenzuwachs der diese inflation
produziert an der sie herumdoktern um
4,6 millionen hat alleine die ezb 76
prozent durch aufkauf von staatsanleihen
in die eigenen bücher genommen damit hat
sie gegen das ausdrückliche verbot der
staatsfinanzierung nach artikel 23 jahre
irgendwo in eklatanter weise verstoßen
der bgh sieht das natürlich alles anders
weil dort die richtermehrheit die
gleiche ist wie die im ezb rat und in
der kommission die eu kommission
flankiert den schulden wahnsinn durch
zusätzliche ebenso wenig als eigene
leben so niedrigen verschuldung in höhe
von 828 milliarden sogenannte resilienz
maßnahmen für überschuldete staaten wozu
das alles ein auseinanderbrechen des eu
regimes soll um jeden preis verhindert
werden wird er war text wer diese union
in einem großstadt verwandten will wie
es der koalitionsvertrag vorsieht der
muss viele nationale demokratien
zerstören die geeignet wären eine solche
entwicklung zu verhindern und sie will
und wird erzeugen einen regier bares
etwas was an die stelle von
nationalstaaten die demokratien sein
können und nur die können demokratien
seien setzen und das genau ist das
ergebnis das ich jetzt in der konferenz
der eu haben mit gezielten teilnehmern
800 555
555 150 millionen einwohnern das muss
eine repräsentative meinungsfreiheit
nach gewesen sein was derzeit von dieser
regierung gemacht wird durch placebos
bei energiekosten kurzzeitige entlastung
von energie steuer und eben auch
verspätete verbesserung von
steuereinnahmen für unternehmen ist der
versuch das eu und ezb versagen national
zu reparieren meine sehr verehrten damen
gern das wird nicht gelingen die eu
staaten befinden sich in einem dilemma
entweder wir die inflation zu einem
massiven kaufkraft und der bevölkerung
zu massenentlassungen von sparern führen
oder wir werden erneut staatsschulden
erschließen erleben die nicht
beherrschbar sind ich komme zum ende
frau präsidentin das alles wird die
existenz des euro
frage stellen ob ihnen das gefällt oder
nicht zum vorgelegten gesetzentwurf
werden wir uns enthalten also cdu-antrag
werden wir zustimmen aber beides meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren wird die
großwetterlage liebsten geschildert habe
nicht verändern
[Applaus]
herr staatsminister der staatsminister
ade machen sie sich keine sorgen meine
sexuelle orientierung wechsel stündlich
der bundestags- vizepräsident wolfgang
kubicki jenem nie während der rede von
albrecht glaser gab es einen wechsel im
präsidium und wolfgang kubicki hat petra
pau abgelöst
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine
lieben kolleginnen und kollegen auch
liebe bürgerinnen und bürgern liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
heute ist ein guter tag für unternehmen
und für sehr sehr viele beschäftigte und
auch für sehr sehr viele geschäft
beschäftigte im gesundheitsbereich
hinter geben gesetzes nahmen 40 corona
steuer hilfe gesetz verbergen sich
ziemlich viele echt tolle dinge für
unternehmen beispielsweise dass endlich
die verlustverrechnung und zwar nicht
nur temporär sondern dauerhaft auf zwei
jahre ausgedehnt wird das wird uns für
zukünftige krisen fit machen und lieber
herr münster ja man hätte auf
rückwirkend noch mehr machen können aber
das ist eine tolle entscheidung mit der
wir uns zukunftsfest aufstellen und
deswegen finde ich die großartig
außerdem
verlängern wir und davon profitieren
auch kleine und mittelständische
unternehmen ganz besonders noch einmal
die investitions fristen denn
lieferketten sind gerade wirklich
schwierig das wissen wir alle und durch
diese verlängerung kann man da auch noch
mal besser von profitieren und den
unternehmen in diesen schwierigen zeiten
kämpfen zum home office hatte der
kollege herr brand schon gesagt es geht
darum jetzt einmal kurzfristig und
dieses gesetz ist ja eine kombination
aus schnellem und pragmatischen handeln
aber auch zukunftsgerichtet schon mal
themen zu adressieren und beim home
office ist es so dass verlängern wir
jetzt einmal die maschine um jagd aber
und dafür war dieser prozess auch sehr
gut wir haben uns darauf geeinigt zu
schauen auch im sinne des arbeitszeiten
arbeitszimmer der ganzen themen die wir
noch beschäftigen wollen was heißt
arbeiten im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert eigentlich und dann nochmal
zu guten aus steuerlichen gesetzgebungen
zu kommen damit wissen anfang gelegt und
das werden wir noch weiter machen
ein ganz besonderes herzensanliegen ist
mir aber heute noch einmal zu betonen
was wir im parlament gemeinsam noch
hinbekommen haben und zwar ziehe ich
mich da ganz ganz besonders darauf dass
wir noch mal deutlich ausgeweitet haben
wer von der steuerfreiheit profitieren
dass beim pflege bonus aber eben auf
anderen boni so viele menschen im
gesundheitswesen haben
unermessliches geleistet und da können
wir nicht nur auf dem krankenhaus
tätigen oder in der langzeitpflege
tätigen sondern wir haben es im
parlament geschafft als finanz
politikerinnen und auch als
gesundheitspolitikerin zu schauen dass
auch die fast eine million medizinischen
fachangestellten die vielen im
rettungsdienst tätigen personen dass
auch diese zumindest mit einer
steuerfreiheit von dem bonus eine
gewisse finanzielle wertschätzung auch
mal haben und das ist großartig und
darüber freue ich mich ganz persönlich
ganz besonders
nochmals die detail ist es eben nicht
nur für tarifliche bohnen auch für
freiwillig gezahlte und eben für einen
sehr sehr großen personenkreis
und dann es fühlt sich vielleicht erst
mal vom norden her wieder technische an
aber die steuer beratungsfristen
kleinere und mittelständische
unternehmen auch größere unternehmen die
korona hilfen bekommen haben wissen wie
unfassbar aufwendig das auch ist jetzt
in den steuererklärungen das alles
nochmal abzuwickeln die
überbrückungshilfe wir hatten und die
steuerkanzleien sie sich damit
beschäftigt haben die über 50.000 und
die hunderttausenden menschen die in
steuerkanzleien arbeiten die haben eine
riesige last da gerade vor sich und da
haben wir jetzt vorausschauend über sehr
viele jahre ein gutes abschmelzen das
modell geschaffen was sogar über den
gesetzentwurf noch hinausgeht und da
sind glaube ich gerade alle ich höre in
die szene hinein wirklich dankbar und
froh darüber dass wir da das gemacht
haben und sozialer ist es auch noch denn
anders als die vorgängerregierung
ermöglichen wir auch menschen die gar
nicht beratungspflicht ich sind endlich
auf ein bisschen mehr fristen zu haben
ein bisschen mehr entlassungen denn
jetzt nach dem chor ohne einschränkungen
diesen sommer möchte man vielleicht auch
lieber mal rausgehen als sich
hinzusetzen und seine steuererklärung
sofort dann endlich fertig zu machen
ich möchte mich es war mein erstes
gesetz was ich wirklich als
berichterstatterin begleitet habe und es
hat mir richtig viel freude bereite ich
mich auch an dieser stelle einmal
persönlich bedanken bei der
parlamentarischen staatssekretärin
hessel mit der wir den dialog werden bei
markus herbrand bei maximilian mordhorst
bei kazama wie bei der wiener börsen bei
michael studie und natürlich bei meinen
gästen grünen kollegin die das alle
wissen es war mir eine große freude und
dem ausblick
final die degressive es ist sehr gut wir
handeln pragmatisch wir haben denn
schnell als regierung aber wir haben uns
auch vereinbart in zukunft werden wir
den begriff steuern steuern auch noch
einmal weiterentwickeln in bezug auf
zukunftsfähigkeit und investitionen in
klimaschutz in digitalisierung noch
besser anreizen und auch da freue ich
mich sehr auf den prozess das klug und
zukunftsweisend hinzubekommen herzlichen
dank ein gutes gesetz ich freue mich auf
die zustimmung
katharina weg gratis für die grünen und
liebt sie auch gesagt ziemlich viele
tolle dinge gewöhnen da drinstehen und
ich kann nochmal aufgreifen was sie
erwähnt hat der finanzausschuss der hat
noch mal was nachgebessert einem
regierungsentwurf nämlich geplanten
vorschriften zur steuerfreien auszahlung
ist pflege bonus sind noch mal
verbessert worden
wurde über den pflege bonus oder über
die sonderzahlung der rede viel zu lange
wurde geklatscht statt zu zahlen und
auch verzeihen sie mir frau kollegin
deckt damit sich ihre harmonie ein
bisschen hier nicht störe diese
koalitionsinterne fingerhakeln im
zusammenhang über welche bereiche wir
bei der steuerfreiheit hier reden war
doch bezeichnend genau dafür und ich
möchte auch die gelegenheit nutzen den
pflegerinnen und pfleger meinen höchsten
respekt zollen denn sie waren es die uns
durch diese pandemie geführt haben denn
sie waren und sind das rückgrat in
unserem gesundheitssystem und das
mindeste meine damen und herren sehr
geehrter herr maly ist dass er jetzt
gott sei dank noch die kurve bekommen
haben und den empfängerkreis ausgeweitet
haben oder aber wir plädieren als linke
auch für einen deutlich höheren bonus
einer der auf die besonderen leistungen
der pflege auch wirklich gerecht wird
erst recht vor dem hintergrund der
explodierenden preise die wir alle
feststellen und diese achsen zählerei
der letzten wochen und monate waren
nicht nur respektlos sondern sie hat
auch noch den vierten den pflegerinnen
und auch noch viel geld gekostet und
meine damen und herren die links
fraktion begrüßt natürlich die home
office pauschale und dass sie verlängert
wird auch bis zum
31.12 aber liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der koalition alle fakten für
eine verlängerung liegen auf dem tisch
da müssen wir doch nicht noch eine
ehrenrunde drehen stichwort
kurzarbeitergeld auch hier eine ganz
klare zustimmung der linken zum
grundsatz dass das kurzarbeitergeld
steuerfrei gestellt wird gleichzeitig
enttäuscht sind wir natürlich im vierten
anlauf bei diesem cola steuer hilfe
gesetz dem progressionsvorbehalt beim
kurzarbeitergeld nicht abschaffen
typischer politik spreche
progressionsvorbehalt verstehen die
menschen in meinem wahlkreis in der
lausitz möglicherweise nicht dass wir
hier kurz erklärt er nur das
kurzarbeitergeld ist steuerfrei aber zur
ermittlung des einkommens steuersatzes
wird das auch das reguläre einkommen
angerechnet so dass die kurzarbeiter
höhere steuertarife möglicherweise zu
befürchten die folge ist lang sind
inzwischen frage der kollegin beck ja
gerne
ich war grad noch beim thema
fingerhakeleien und wollte an dieser
stelle irgendwie in eine frage verpacken
dass ich mich sehr gefreut habe dass
auch sie gestern der ausweitung der
bonuszahlungen und der steuerfreiheit
zugestimmt haben das fand ich sehr
schönes haben übrigens alle fraktionen
dem zugestimmt und deswegen als frage
irgendwie verpackt hier an der stelle
noch mal die frage warum sie da jetzt so
doll kritisch darauf eingehen vielleicht
wenn sie dem doch zugestimmt haben
seine
kollegen vorher weil sie sich von ihrem
platz geben
natürlich haben wir diese auswertung
dazu gestimmt aber sie haben als
koalition im zusammenhang mit dem pflege
bonus und der steuerfreiheit glaube ich
als allererste maßnahme hier im november
des letzten jahres also vor fast sieben
monaten diesen pflege boden die
steuerfreiheit thematisiert und die zeit
die sie gebraucht haben für diese
maßnahmen ist einfach zu lang vor dem
hintergrund dass die menschen die uns
hier durch die krise getragen haben auch
entsprechend honoriert werden und das
wollte ich nicht deutlich machen
aber nochmals den punkt kurzarbeitergeld
zurück herr präsident vielen dank
ich war bei dem bei der post vom
finanzamt und am ende steht natürlich
dann auch eine saftige nachzahlung
möglicherweise bei dem einen oder
anderen die ohnehin schon in der korona
krise viele entbehrungen hinnehmen
mussten und auch einkommensverluste
hinnehmen mussten und viele rechnen und
auch gar nicht damit und da bin ich dann
auch schon beim rechnen zumindest für
den bundeshaushalt hat dass sich
gerechnet dass ungefähr 3,4 milliarden
euro einnahmen durch die progression im
bundeshaushalt dann über den rückweg
gelandet sind ich finde das ist nicht in
ordnung das ist auch eine
unverschämtheit und die leute kommen
sich auch verschaukelt vor auf der einen
seite haben wir die
exorbitanten gewinne der energiekonzerne
auf der anderen seite müssen diese
menschen die in kurzarbeit waren auf
steuerzahlungen möglicherweise warten
und das hat meine damen und herren mit
respekt das hat auch mit fortschritt und
das hat auch nichts mit gerechtigkeit zu
tun und insofern meine forderung und die
bitte entlasten sie die kurzarbeiter-
und besteuern sie endlich diese
krisengewinner und sie haben die
möglichkeit bei uns im antrag über die
über gewinn steuer genau dazu zurück
viel glück
als nächstes hält das vollständige
maximilian
forster
ja sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich glaube wäre
der debatte auch nur halbwegs aufmerksam
gefolgt ist sieht es besteht hier eine
große einigkeit in bezug auf dieses
vierter cola steuer hilfe gesetz und das
ist ja geht bis auf eine zu mir mir
zumindest sehr lang vorkommen der krude
eu vorlesung gab es nicht mal von der
linken eine grundsatzkritik an dem was
wir hier machen als sie können sich
sicher sein wenn wir eine so breite
mehrheit dieses hauses haben dann kann
man glaube ich abschließend sagen dass
kroner steuer hilfe gesetz es ist sehr
gut und deswegen kann man ihn mit gutem
gewissen auch zustimmen ich will
deswegen gar nicht so viel während eurer
zeit in anspruch nehmen möchte auch noch
auf das eine oder andere eingehen was
die union ja teilweise von uns
abgeschrieben hat was mir aber doch ein
bisschen sorge bereitet ist und das
glaube ich sollten wir uns schon merken
vielleicht noch als ergänzung zu den
bisher genannten punkten wir beschließen
hier ein crooner corona steuer hilfe
gesetz und dass sie da maßnahmen
vorschlagen viele davon sind ausnahmen
ich würde mich freuen wenn wir das ein
oder andere auch verlängern aber dass
sie hier maßnahmen vorschlagen
beispielsweise bei den steuerberater
fristen die bis 2029 laufen sollen als
ich den optimismus sollten wir uns schon
zutrauen dass wir solche sondergesetze
dann nicht mehr brauchen dass wir da
vernünftige änderungen hinbekommen gerne
aber solche ausnahme lösung waren corona
steuer hilfe gesetz glaube ich die sind
da gerade feilt untergebracht ist passt
aber zu dem steuerpolitischen potpourri
dass man in ihrem antrag so ein bisschen
sieht alles was man in den letzten 16
jahren nicht gemacht hat packt man jetzt
mal so ein bisschen zusammen und
versucht es durchzusetzen ich glaube wir
haben in den letzten
acht monaten schon eine ganze menge auf
den weg gebracht wir werden das weiter
machen und deswegen kann ich nur darum
bitten stimmen sie dem vierten kroner
steuer hilfe gesetz zu es ist sehr gut
das kann ja mal ein ordentlich kurze
rede im nächster redner ist herr kollege
sebastian brehm cdu csu fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
wir haben ja schon in unserer zeit als
bundesregierung in der damaligen großen
koalition die korona steuer hilfe
gesetze 1 2 und 3 auf den weg gebracht
mit wichtigen maßnahmen
kurzarbeitergeld überbrückungshilfen die
möglichkeit der inanspruchnahme von kfw
krediten und vielen vielen anderen
maßnahmen und wir haben damit mit diesen
gesetzen in der pandemie der wirtschaft
unter die arme gegriffen und
stabilisiert deshalb wenn man das
rückwirkend auch betrachtet muss man
sagen es ist gelungen die
insolvenzquote war so niedrig wie noch
nie wir konnten arbeitslosigkeit
verhindern und die betriebe wieder in
die zukunft führen auch die
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmern
deswegen ist das vierte corona steuer
hilfe gesetz auch konsequent und setzt
die maßnahme die wir damals mit
aufgesetzt haben ford und deswegen
stimmen wir diesen gesetz auch zu über
kollege mordhorst ob das ein sehr gutes
gesetzes das weiß ich jetzt nicht da
fehlen natürlich noch wesentliche
inhalte die sie übrigens immer selber
auch beantragt haben nicht kommen dann
später noch mal drauf aber wenn
natürlich konsequenterweise die
maßnahmen fortgeführt werden die wir
auch beschlossen haben dann ist es eben
auch richtig diesem gesetz zuzustimmen
aber unsere aufgabe liebe kolleginnen
kollegen de unsere aufgabe als
opposition ist es gute anträge zu
unterstützen aber auch den finger in die
wunde zu legen wenn noch dinge fielen
deswegen haben wir unsere
entschließungsantrag auf den weg
gebracht weil wir glaube ich deutlich
ansprechen müssen was in diesem gesetz
fehlt also erstens die steuerfreie
zuschüsse zum kurzarbeitergeld werden um
sechs monate verlängert konsequent und
richtig haben wir auch damals mit
angestoßen bei der home office pauschale
die kollegen kollegen da muss ich ein
bisschen schmunzeln
es ist ein ureigenes thema der csu
gewesen die home office pauschale
sozusagen auf den weg zu bringen was wir
der diskussionen geführt haben die
überhaupt durchzubekommen bei den
kolleginnen und kollegen der spd es war
ja wahnsinn in dem gesetz und jetzt
verlängern sie es und schreibens auf
ihre fahne aber ich bin ja dankbar dafür
dass sie es tun und ich bin gespannt
übrigens auf die vorschläge die da
kommen zu einer erweiterung der home
office pauschale und einer verstetigung
wir hätten uns vorstellen können dass
wir die verstetigung auch jetzt schon in
diesem gesetzentwurf 10
die möglichkeit der inanspruchnahme
degressive abschreibung ist in ordnung
und ist richtig auch hier hätte man eine
entfristung vornehmen können aber gut es
ist ein wichtiger und richtiger schritt
die fristen zur abgabe der
steuererklärungen piraten fällen auch da
haben sie zunächst in ihrem
gesetzentwurf eine verkürzung dieser
fristen vorgenommen sie haben das
zurückgeführt das abschmelzen modell was
sie gesagt haben aber gerade in einer
zeit in der die steuer künstler ein
extreme belastungen haben extreme
belastungen haben corona hilfen
beantragen die schlussrechnung der
korona hilfen die grundsteuer
beantragung juli bis oktober muss eine
erklärungsfrist verlängert werden und
sie haben fast eins zu eins
dankenswerterweise unsere intervention
wahrgenommen unseren antrag umgesetzt
danke dafür dass sie das getan haben
die verlängerung der investitionskosten
ist folgerichtig im einkommensteuerrecht
für investitions abzugsbeträge und so
weiter
bei der verlustverrechnung da will ich
schon noch mal drauf zu verstetigen den
zweijährigen verlust tragen rück tags
zeitraum aber genau jetzt ist es
handwerklich falsch sie haben ja selber
in der letzten periode anträge gestellt
vier jahre rückt raack die fdp hat mal
drei jahre rücktritt gefordert wenn wir
jetzt verlust rück träge machen vom jahr
2022 in das jahr 2020 dann tragen wir in
ein jahr zurück oder in zwei jahre
zurück die von der pandemie betroffen
waren es hat also null effekt weil 2020
waren bei vielen verlustjahre und sie
tragen jetzt in den verlust zurück wenn
hätten sie ihre antrag ernst nehmen
müssen und auf drei jahre als in das
gewinn jahr 2019 noch mit zurück tragen
müssen das wäre konsequent gewesen
deswegen haben wir es noch mal beantragt
und wenn wir auch mal guten antrag
stellen könnten sie ja auch zustimmen
aber vielleicht bleiben sie da in der
parteipolitischen brille und sagen
machen wir nicht also jetzt wäre es
möglich wir haben sie heute beantragt
sie könnten eigentlich zustimmen tun sie
aber nicht
und ich will noch auf 1 zu sprechen
kommen natürlich im pflegebereich auch
da haben sie gott sei dank noch mal
nachgeschärft weil viele
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter in
ihrem ersten entwurf ausgenommen waren
wir hatten zahlreiche anfragen warum wir
nicht wir sind doch auch im bereich der
pflege tätig wir haben da in der
diskussion des noch erreicht gemeinsam
diesen kreis der berechtigten für den
chor ohne bonus oder für die pflege
bonus auszuweiten das ist richtig aber
eine berufsgruppe das ist glaube ich
auch in der anhörung
zu tage gekommen eine berufs probieren
sie sprechen von respekt liebe kollegin
beck und von wertschätzung eine
berufsgruppe er findet überhaupt nicht
ihre wertschätzung das sind die über
500.000 steuerfachangestellten und
steuerfachleute die in den kanzleien
arbeiten die extrem belastet sind in
dieser zeit und wir hätten uns gewünscht
dass sie zumindest hier die korona
prämie auch ausweiten aber
wahrscheinlich mögen sie diese
berufsgruppe nicht und deswegen haben
sie es hier raus genommen ähnlich wie
beim klima geld nehmen sie einfach
wesentliche teile aus dem gesetz schade
dass sie hier keinen respekt zollen und
es fehlen natürlich wichtige dinge
deswegen haben wir auch ergänzend
unseren antrag gestellt
abschaffung des solidaritätszuschlags
sie klagen ja sogar für die abschaffung
des solidaritätszuschlags hätten sie
rein bringen können jetzt sitzen sie am
steuer und das was sie beklagen setzten
sich um turbo abschreibung kündigen sie
an machen sie nicht und die anpassung
des einkommensteuertarifs wir werden ja
heute nachmittag noch mal drüber reden
tun sie auch nicht in dem maße wie es
notwendig ist also deswegen kein sehr
gutes gesetz sind wichtige punkte der
bei den wir zustimmen aber sie hätten
deutlich mehr machen können herzlichen
dank nun dank akku sebastian brehm war
das für die unionsfraktionen mitglied im
finanzausschuss dort ist das ganze ja
vor allem behandelt worden und
wir hören jetzt für die spd nadine
heselhaus
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren das vierte corona steuer hilfe
gesetz steht in einer reihe von hilfen
die die finanziellen auswirkungen der
pandemie auf die menschen in deutschland
verringern bürgerinnen und bürger und
unternehmen erfahren steuerliche
entlastungen dabei muss man ehrlich
zugeben dass der staat hätten nie
vollständig ausgleichen kann auch die
der pandemie nicht wir mildern die
belastungen für die bevölkerung ab dabei
haben wir alle menschen im blick
insbesondere jene mit niedrigem
einkommen
[Musik]
die arbeitsbelastung wurde in vorherigen
reden bereits angesprochen insbesondere
im gesundheitswesen ist diese
außerordentlich hoch die wertschätzung
für die arbeit der pflegekräfte und
anderer gruppen stieg in der letzten
zeit deutlich an vielen menschen wurde
noch einmal bewusst welchen stellenwert
die arbeit im gesundheitsbereich für
unsere gesellschaft hat uns ist es
wichtig diese herausragende leistung und
der einsatz nicht nur öffentliche
wertschätzung dass diese herausragende
leistung unter einsatz nicht nur
öffentliche wertschätzung erfahren
sondern sich auch im geldbeutel
widerspiegeln wir arbeiten langfristig
an besseren löhnen und
arbeitsbedingungen weil nur tariflöhne
eine ordentliche bezahlung garantieren
und darüber hinaus muss der besondere
einsatz der letzten zeit auch besonders
entlohnt werden können deshalb haben wir
uns für einen pflege bonus in höhe von
insgesamt einer milliarde euro
eingesetzt und damit der bonus auch im
portemonnaie ankommt stellen wir jetzt
zahlungen bis zu 4500 euro steuerfrei
die steuerpflichtigen insgesamt und auch
die steuerberatenden berufe sind durch
die andauernde corona pandemie weiterhin
belastet diesbezüglich haben wir in den
vergangenen jahren die steuerlichen
abgabefristen immer wieder verlängert
und so auch für zeitliche entlastung
gesorgt
schon jetzt können wir damit rechnen
dass es in den kanzleien durch die
bearbeitung der korona hilfen und der
grundsteuer zu mehrbelastungen in den
folgenden jahren kommen wird daher
erweitern wir die frist für das
steuerjahr
2020 und denen diese auch abgestuft für
die kommenden jahre aus die
verlängerungen werden dann schrittweise
zurückgeführt so dass ab dem
besteuerungs zeitraum 2025 wieder die
regulären termine und fristen für
beratende fälle zur anwendung kommen
werden auch diejenigen die ihre
steuererklärung selbst erstellen
erhalten verlängerte abgabefristen für
die steuerjahre bis 2023 mit dieser
vorausschauenden regelung der
abgabefristen schaffen wir
planungssicherheit für steuerpflichtige
für die kanzleien und auch für die
verwaltung
das vierte coroner steuer hilfe gesetz
enthält darüber hinaus eine reihe von
maßnahmen die arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer im besonderen unterstützen
von der steuerlichen förderung der
zuschüsse zum kurzarbeitergeld bis hin
zu home office pauschale in der kroner
pandemie arbeiten viele
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer und
auch viele selbstständige im home office
oft fehlen dabei die voraussetzungen für
ein häusliches arbeitszimmer viele
arbeiten in einer arbeitsecke am küchen
oder eben auch am esstisch um auch
diesen erwerbstätigen einen steuerlichen
abzug zu ermöglichen hat die vorherige
regierung und insbesondere hubertus heil
eine home office pauschale eingeführt
so kann auch weg ein echtes
arbeitszimmer hat
bis zu 600 euro im jahr als
werbungskosten geltend machen
diese gut angenommene maßnahme
verlängern wir auch für das jahr
wir sehen dass viele menschen immer mehr
geld für das nötigste ausgeben müssen
darauf hat die bundesregierung reagiert
und zwei entlastungs paket in höhe von
fast 30 milliarden euro beschlossen
dieses vierte corona steuer hilfe gesetz
kommt noch dazu denn entlastung muss in
diesen tagen breit angelegt sein
als nächster redner enthält das wort
kollegin dr sandra letzter bündnis 90
die grünen
sehr verehrter präsident die wir
kolleginnen und kollegen
wir haben dieses gesetz vorgelegt und da
hatte meine vorrednerin jetzt gerade das
richtige gesagt dazu in der hoffnung
unternehmern und den menschen
unterstützung zukommen zu lassen und die
negativen wirtschaftlichen folgen der
krise abzufedern aber natürlich sind wir
uns sehr bewusst dass wir die kompletten
folgen natürlich nicht abfedern können
und deswegen danke ich all denjenigen
die verständnis dafür haben dass wir als
gesetzgeber eben nicht alles auffangen
können was an daten auf trifft das
bringt viele an die leistungsfähigkeit
an die ende ihrer kräfte und wenn sie da
einfach ein ganz klein bisschen
nachsehen mit uns haben wir uns das sehr
sehr lieb und dafür möchte ich mich
herzlich bedanken
kolleginnen und kollegen haben die ganze
vielzahl der maßnahmen auch schon
aufgezählt wir auf den weg gebracht
haben und ich will einen zweiten
gedanken da vielleicht eher zufügen
insbesondere natürlich bei der
unterstützung von unternehmen die wir
jetzt hier vornehmen ist die
verlängerung der degressiven
abschreibung die verlängerung der
investitions fristen auch die dauerhafte
ausweitung des zeitraums für den verlust
zurücktrat natürlich ganz entscheidend
und ja die kollegin weg hat es ja auch
schon gesagt beim verlust rück tag
hätten wir uns grüne auch gerade im
kontext der pandemie noch mal
verlängerte rücktritt zurück trucks
füssen vorstellen können denn was die
kollegen von der cdu sagen sind ja das
ja ganz genau richtig wir sind natürlich
in der situation dass wir jetzt mit den
rückt regen genau die pandemie bekommen
das wissen wir auch allerdings
allerdings jetzt ist der punkt den ich
machen will wir haben natürlich in der
situation schon auch immer das
gesamtbild im blick zu halten und wir
müssen sehen dass die das meer sozusagen
an liquidität was jetzt die unternehmen
gerade dann durch den verlust rückgrat
ja bekommen natürlich schon auch ein
weniger an die qualität für die
öffentlichen haushalte bedeutet also
dass bund länder und kommunen daran
stückchen weit in vorleistung gehen auch
für die liquidität und ich glaube wir
dürfen krage die länder und die kommunen
deren haushalte ja auch von den corona
folgen gezeichnet sind da eben nicht
überlasten und ich glaube deswegen macht
eben genau dieser zeitraum von zwei
jahren den wir gewählt haben sind und es
ist ein guter kompromiss
jetzt will ich zu ende noch einen
gedanken loswerden denn heute sind ja
wirklich viele berufsgruppen zu recht
genannt worden und ich will ganz
besonders jetzt einer sanften das sind
die beschäftigten in den
steuerverwaltungen denn wir wissen
natürlich ganz genau dass sie in den
finanzämtern das rückgrat einfach des
deutschen staates sind und dass ihre
gute arbeit die staatlichen einnahmen
und ja auch die steuergerechtigkeit in
diesem land sicherte und natürlich ist
jetzt die steuerverwaltung
wissen sie meine verehrten kolleginnen
sache der länder und dennoch ist uns
grün natürlich sehr sehr bewusst dass
wir mit diesem cola steuer hilfe gesetz
noch einmal zusätzliche belastungen auch
für die verwaltung schaffen und es sind
mehr aufgaben die erstmal zu stemmen
sind deswegen an dieser stelle nochmal
herzlichen dank an die beschäftigten in
den finanzämtern sie sind es die dieses
vierte corinna steuer hilfe gesetz zum
erfolg machen herzlichen dank
das sagte sandra des örv für bündnis
90/die grünen und ein weiteres mitglied
im finanzausschuss ist wohlauf coating
er spricht jetzt für die union präsident
werde kolleginnen und kollegen vor 40
tagen haben wir hier das vierte corona
steuer hilfe gesetz zum ersten mal
debattiert und besprochen und schon da
habe ich seit deutlich gemacht dass die
fortführung bewährter steuerliche
maßnahmen in der krisenzeit durchaus ein
probates mittel ist um
unkompliziert hilfen zur verfügung zu
stellen für die menschen für die
unternehmen die von der krise betroffen
sind aber und das ist entscheidend mit
den jetzt vorgesehenen
minimalinvasiven korrekturen bei diesem
gesetz können sie von der anwalt des von
ihnen gesteckte ziel nicht erreichen
dann das gesteckte ziel war ja die
wirtschaftlichen und sozialen
einschränkungen durch die korona
pandemie so gering wie auch immer
möglich zu halten und es reicht deswegen
nicht was hier vorliegt weil es
mittlerweile ja nicht mehr nur alleine
um die folgen der korona krise geht
sondern es geht um die wirtschaftlichen
konsequenzen des unsäglichen
angriffskrieges von russland auf die
ukraine es geht um die rapide steigende
inflation und die muss die
bundesregierung entschlossen bekämpfen
und das insbesondere deswegen weil da
steht uns so hat das gröbste noch bevor
ja sie haben in der tat schon mehrere
gesetzentwürfe vorgelegt das geht ja
nicht nur hier um dieses einzige gesetz
aber all diesen gesetzen die hier in den
letzten wochen vorgelegt werden
haben eines gemeinsam es sind zwar gute
ansätze enthalten aber es wird überall
zu kurz gesprungen
da werden maßnahmen bis zwei coroner
steuer hilfe gesetzes wie die
verlängerung von verlust
verrechnungsmöglichkeiten oder die
degressiven abschreibung für bewegliche
wirtschaftsgüter und auch die
steuerlichen investitions fristen
verlängert aber man muss sich doch
fragen ob diese maßnahmen tatsächlich in
der praxis den unternehmen entsprechend
helfen und vor allem mittelständische
unternehmen müssen doch erstmal in die
lage versetzt werden verlustfrei zu
wirtschaften und in die zukunft zu
investieren
und dazu brauchen wir stark verbesserte
wirtschaftspolitische und steuerliche
rahmenbedingungen
um endlich da jetzt in dieser
krisensituation auch die
rahmenbedingungen zu schaffen und das
muss die bundesregierung eben jetzt
umsetzen und nicht erst in einigen
monaten oder in jahren ankündigungen und
jedenfalls und markige sprüche reichen
hier nicht sondern wir brauchen jetzt
taten nur dann wird wieder in die
zukunft investiert deswegen liebe ampel
stärken sie die eigenkapitalbasis der
betriebe passen sie die behandlung von
gewinnen die zur stärkung der
eigenkapitalbasis unternehmen
einbehalten werden der jetzigen
situation an die thesaurierung
vergünstigung die muss praktikabler
werden sie muss praktisch
praxistauglicher und attraktiver gerade
auch für kleine und mittlere unternehmen
gemacht werden
und in dieser situation
das haben wir jetzt schon mehrfach hier
gehört muss auch der ertrag steuerliche
verlustvortrag zeitraum auch mindestens
drei jahre erhöht wird gerade jetzt wo
es um die krisenjahre 20 21 22 geht dann
macht es doch keinen sinn und kollege
bremen wollen schon mal deutlich gemacht
wir können doch nicht ein corona
verlustjahr mit einem corona verlustjahr
verrechnen das macht ja nun überhaupt
keinen sinn deswegen muss das dauerhaft
ausgeweitet werden und wir haben das ja
auch entsprechend beantragt
und was eben auch fehlt in diesem gesetz
ist das thema wie gehen wir damit um
dass die betriebe die in russland
klatten keine investiert sind jetzt von
sanktionen enteignungen zerstörungen
betroffen sind die dortigen
beteiligungen deutscher
steuerpflichtiger die müssen auch
entsprechend jetzt berücksichtigt werden
da brauchen wir temporär steuerliche
abschreibungen das muss einfach hier in
so ein gesetz in der aktuellen situation
mit aufgenommen werden
sie haben in den beratungen in den
letzten vierzig tagen bei diesem
gesetzgebungsverfahren leider nur wenig
bewegt eine kleine verbesserung nämlich
die verlängerung der
steuererklärungspflicht die haben sie
hinbekommen das finden wir auch gut das
ist gelungen durch den druck der cdu csu
fraktion aber auch der bundesländer des
bundesrates und das sind das ist gut
ausdrücklich finden wir das richtig und
gut meine grundsätzliche unterstützung
gilt im übrigen auch allen regelungen
die den arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmern zugute kommen die
angesprochene fristen verlängerung die
förderung des feuer steuerfreien
zuschuss beim kurzarbeitergeld
die verlängerung bei der home office
pauschale alles richtig alles gut aber
warum entfristen cs da nicht warum immer
nur eine kurzfristige verlängerung eine
entfristung wäre hier besser ist wäre
das richtige signal für arbeitnehmer und
für die unternehmen
und auch die hier schon angesprochenen
bonuszahlungen da können wir
selbstverständlich den vorgenommenen
änderungen zustimmen
ich glaube es macht sinn dass wir die
leistungen der beschäftigten im
gesundheits und pflegebereich
honorieren aber eins muss man auch noch
mal unterstreichen das ist keine
automatische auszahlung die hier
vorgenommen wird es wird ja immer so der
eindruck erweckt als ob das schon sicher
wäre es gehört auch hier noch der
arbeitgeber dazu da dass entsprechend
auszahlen muss und dieser wunsch zur
eingrenzung dann kann ich auch verstehen
wir wollen natürlich hier nicht mehr den
gleichen fehler machen wie bei den bonus
aus der ersten pole regelung dass die
mitglieder des bundesvorstands der
grünen sicher bedienen können soll
natürlich nicht mehr vorkommen deswegen
diese einschränkung ist richtig ihren
einsatz beginnen
ich kann diesem gesetzentwurf zustimmen
das hatten wir schon angekündigt hält
aber ich werde gleichzeitig auch um
zustimmung für unseren
entschließungsantrag mut zu wesentlichen
steuerlichen hilfsmaßnahmen dieser
erhält richtig und steuerlichen hat wird
auch in tschechien jetzt das wort es
hätte gerne
[Applaus]
da der bundestags- vizepräsident
wolfgang kubicki der achtet auf die
redezeiten die debatten haben ja alle
vom ältestenrat festgelegte debatten
zeit die fraktionen teilen dann ihrer
größe entsprechend den verschiedenen
rednern
minuten rede minuten zu und der
bundestags-vizepräsident wolfgang
kubicki hat natürlich auch jeden
tagesordnung heute im blick die noch bis
mitternacht geht meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen von der union und auch im
sonstigen saal bei der bewältigung der
korona pandemie ist unser oberstes ziel
seit jahren gewählt die wirtschaftlichen
und sozialen belange so gering wie
möglich zu belasten
daher sieht das heute zu beschließende
gesetz über steuerliche maßnahmen
zugunsten von bürgerinnen und bürger und
unternehmen eine ganze menge von
maßnahmen vor ich wäre da auch gleich
noch drauf eingehen da aber die
kolleginnen kollegen der union jetzt so
häufig ihren entschließungsantrag mut zu
wesentlichen steuerlichen hilfsmaßnahmen
also er hört sich ja sehr staatstragend
aber er ist jetzt wirklich auch ziemlich
dünn das sind gerade mal zwölf
forderungen da drin hier so hoch loben
will ich dann doch auch da etwas drauf
eingehen im grunde genommen ist ihr
antrag nichts anderes als ein
steuerpolitisches sammelsurium oder ein
steuerpolitisches kraut und rüben ein
durcheinander von forderungen die sie
immer mal wieder gestellt haben aber nie
selber haben durchsetzen können
man kann man kann natürlich auch sagen
es handelt sich um einen klientel antrag
ein klientel an tragen wie nicht anders
zu erwarten
adressieren sie vor allen dingen
unternehmen an die arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer denken sie da mit ihren
vorschlägen eher weniger jedenfalls drei
viertel drei viertel von tilman ihrer
vorschläge beziehen sich ausschließlich
auf die unternehmensbesteuerung in
diesem antrag wenn man sich genau
anguckt und wenn man sich ernsthaft dann
inhaltlich mit dem einzelnen forderungen
auch noch beschäftigen möchte dann kommt
man natürlich auch zu der frage wie soll
das denn tatsächlich finanziert werden
also sie müssen ja nicht nur vorschläge
machen sondern sie müssen sie auch
irgendwie gehen finanzieren denn
immerhin wurden ihre vorschläge im
bundeshaushalt einige milliarden
geringere einnahmen produzieren
gegenfinanzierung in ihrem antrag
fehlanzeige
zur finanzierung ihrer großzügigen
steuergeschenke findet man lediglich den
die maßnahmen sollen ich zitiere im
rahmen der verfügbaren haushaltsmittel
zitat ende durch die bundesregierung
umgesetzt werden ja echt jetzt liebe
union was bedeutet dass der ganz
konkretes bedeutet sie haben sich noch
nicht mal die mühe gemacht ihre eigenen
vorschläge durchzurechnen und
gegenzufinanzieren also ziemlich dünn
was davor liegt
ich freue mich aber das haben sie am
anfang auch gesagt dass sie
schlussendlich doch noch überzeugt
wurden und dem gesetzentwurf des corona
steuer hilfe gesetzes zustimmen würden
werden ihr antrag ist natürlich da nicht
besonders förderlich
wir dagegen kümmern uns um die menschen
und um die unternehmen in unserem land
sie sind uns eben nicht egal und deshalb
haben wir auch mit den beiden
entlastungspaket die wir in den
vergangenen wochen ja schon besprochen
haben zahlreiche entlastungen und auch
mit diesem corona steuer hilfe gesetz
auf den weg gebracht die sowohl für die
menschen für die arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer wichtig sind und auch für
die unternehmen und das ist gute
fortschrittliche politik meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren denn ich will
das mal ganz kurz und komprimiert noch
zusammenfassen die maßnahmen die wir in
dem entsprechenden
steuerentlastungsgesetz durchgesetzt
haben anhebung grundfreibetrag anregung
arbeitnehmerpauschbetrag vorziehen der
befristeten anhebung der
entfernungspauschale für fernpendler
energiepreis pauschale kinderbonus durch
diese bereits verabschiedeten
entlastungspaket werden die bürgerinnen
und bürger insgesamt sich um 16
milliarden euro entlastet das ist auch
nicht nichts dafür muss man sich auch
nicht entschuldigt dass es gut und
richtig dass wir es so beschlossen haben
bitte
um gerade darauf hingewiesen dass sie
sich nicht entschuldigen müssen für
entlastungen würden sie sich bereit
erklären sich bei rentnerinnen und
rentnern und bafög empfängern zu
entschuldigen dass sie die mit den
kosten alleine sitzen gelassen haben
sehr geehrte frau kollegin 10 auf die
rentnerinnen und rentner profitieren
natürlich von dem entlastungspaket auch
sie werden das neuen euro ticket nutzen
können auch sie kriegen die
heizkostenpauschale wenn sie wohngeld
empfängerinnen und empfänger sind auch
sie bekommen zum beispiel die
energiespeicher die eeg-umlage senkt und
mit es sind ausreichende entlastung für
alle menschen in diesem paket enthalte
aber
also das steuerentlastungspaket vorteil
man ist ja auch nicht alles deshalb
bringen wir ja heute auch weitere
steuerliche maßnahmen auf den weg für
die arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
corona sonderzahlungen werden bis zu
4500 euro steuerfrei und bei der
grundsicherung von arbeitssuchenden
nicht angerechnet wir verlängern die
home office pauschale wie bereits schon
sehr umfassend ausgeführt wurde wir
verlängern die steuerfreiheit beim
kurzarbeitergeld die wirtschaftliche
erholung führt durch zusätzliche
investitionen und investitionsanreize
für unternehmen unterstützt dazu
verbessern wir die möglichkeiten der
verlustverrechnung die degressive
abschreibung für bewegliche
wirtschaftsgüter des anlagevermögens
vermögens wird verlängert und
steuerliche investitions fristen
ausgeweitet und zur steuerbefreiung des
pflege bonus hat ja auch mein kollege
paar samani entsprechend ausgeführt
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der union
als opposition kann man ja immer mal ein
bisschen knapper und sagen es ist das
luft nach oben und da muss noch mehr
kommen aber im grunde des herzens wissen
sie ganz genau diese regierung tut den
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmern und
den unternehmen gut und deshalb werden
wir auch diesen gesetzentwurf zustimmen
mit
vielen dank frau kollegin
der frauke heiligenstadt war das für die
spd-fraktion und jetzt hören wir viel
grünen mit saskia und weishaupt
präsident liebe kolleginnen in meiner
letzten rede habe ich davon gesprochen
dass es auch berufsgruppen gibt die eben
nicht vom pflege bonus gesetz
profitieren werden die aber letztendlich
alles dafür getan haben dass wir gut
durch die pandemie kommen und immer noch
gut durch diese partie gehen werden
darunter fallen die vielen vielen
medizinischen fachangestellten die neben
den normalen praxisalltag teils tausende
impfungen durchgeführt und organisiert
haben aber auch immer die erste
anlaufstelle waren für die vielen corona
patientinnen und das mit der ständigen
angst sich selber zu infizieren und das
mit in ihre familie diese infektion zu
schleppen und in ihrem freundeskreis
aber es sind nicht nur die medizinischen
fachangestellten
es sind auch die rettungssanitäterin die
gasversorgung gemanagt haben und immer
einem boot infektionsrisiko ausgesetzt
waren sie haben einen besonders
schwierigen phasen in der pandemie mit
intensiv transporten eine größere
katastrophe und die vollständige
überlastung einzelner krankenhäuser
letztendlich verhindert und ehrlich
gesagt möchte ich diese zeit nehmen und
deswegen hören sie vielleicht auch noch
mal genauer zu wir müssen diesen
menschen danke sagen
aber es war klar ein es kann ich bei
danksagungen bleiben sondern wir
erweitern deshalb nach grünen vorschlag
die steuerfreiheit für freiwillige boni
und wir schließen die beiden erwähnten
berufsgruppen mit einem noch viele
weitere berufsgruppen und arbeitnehmer
in indy werten einrichtungen doch was
bedeutet das konkret letztendlich zum
einen schaffen wir den andere hat sie
beschäftigen für die zusätzlichen
belastung zu entlohnen und zum anderen
sind diese sonderleistungen für die
menschen die so viel geleistet haben in
der pandemie steuerfrei wenn jetzt also
beispielsweise eine ärztin ihre
medizinischen fachangestellten einen
bonus zahlen möchte kommt dieser im
vollem maße auf dem konto der
beschäftigten an und das ist ein
riesenerfolg
es ist ein klares signal an die vielen
beschäftigten dass sie ihre arbeit
wertschätzen sondern ist auch ein
zeichen an die berufsverbände und an die
menschen der praxis die forderungen und
die stellungnahmen der verschiedensten
verbände sind in unserer arbeit mit
eingeflossen und ist ein zeichen dass
ihren zuhören und sie ernst damit
gehen wir wirklich den ersten richtigen
und wichtigen schritt in richtung
wertschätzung der gesundheitsberufe
aber ehrlich gesagt und das wissen ja
alle was haben wir schon sehr oft gesagt
dabei kann es nicht bleiben mit
abschriften des gesetzes müssen wir uns
neu fokussieren wir müssen die
arbeitsbedingungen in den
gesundheitsberufen verbessern und für
mich bedeutet das sehr konkret wir
müssen die berufs gesetze der
gesundheitsberufe modernisieren auch
hier werden wir und müssen wir mit den
berufsverbänden zusammen arbeiten ihnen
zuhören und antworten und lösungen
finden für drängende fragen
und ich bin mir sicher als
ampelkoalition werden wir richtige und
wichtige schritte gehen um diese berufs
gesetze ins 21 jahrhundert zu holen
vielen dank
und ein redner haben wir noch hier bevor
dann über den gesetzentwurf zum vierten
cola steuer hilfe gesetz abgestimmt wird
michael schrodi wird es dann für die spd
der finanzpolitische sprecher
sind meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren ich habe mal angeschaut das erste
krone steuer hilfe gesetz war im april
2020 der hamburg auf den weg gebracht
die steuerbefreiung zuschüsse
arbeitgeber zum kurzarbeitergeld machen
weil setzen wir fort wir sind beim
vierten grundsteuer hilfe gesetz
angelangt das sieht man die kante wiese
nicht vorbei die folgen sind nicht
vorbei wir müssen weiterhin etwas tun
wir setzen vieles von dem ford was wir
angelegt haben in der großen koalition
wo vieles richtig war wo wir den
menschen und den unternehmen geholfen
haben ich glaube nicht dass wir
irgendwie in sack und asche gehen müssen
dafür was wir tun es sind zwölf
milliarden euro die wir auch mit diesem
gesetz auf den weg bringen wir haben am
anfang der letzten legislatur noch um
zwölf millionen vielleicht gestritten
jetzt geht es um zwölf milliarden sind
riesige pakete die auf den weg bringen
um die wirtschaft zu stützen um den
menschen zu helfen und ich glaube das
ist ein gutes signal mit dieser
applikation es wieder entsprechend auch
geben und
darf man sich auch loben der künstler
auch viele depressive a förmigen es sind
zehn milliarden euro die wir da auf den
weg bringen ich glaube das kann man
schon mal betonen dass wir das tun dass
wir andere weitere maßnahme mit auf den
weg bringen übrigens was wenig ganz
gefällt auch bei der zwischen frage von
frau kümmern wir fangen immer an
einzelnen maßnahmen sehr isoliert für
sich zu betrachten sagt mal hier mal da
ein bisschen mehr und da hat wenn ich
mal zusammenfassen was werden
überbrückungshilfen
kinderbonus
heizkostenzuschüsse kurzarbeitergeld
wirtschafts stabilisierungsfonds was wir
da alles auf den weg bringen dann kann
man nicht an der einen kleinen schraube
sagen da hätten wir noch ein bisschen
mehr sonne insgesamt können es steht
übrigens auch bei dem thema energiepreis
pauschale und natürlich tun wir was für
renten renten natürlich für studierende
und ich glaube diese gesamtschau muss
man schon auch mal in den blick nehmen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die schon
genommen sondern zwischen frage aus der
administration ein
und wir tun auch was und das finde ich
auch wichtig zu betonen weil sich da
viel bei der union auch im bereich des
unternehmens steuerrechts befindet auch
für arbeitnehmerinnen arbeitnehmer und
her gut ding wenn sie das sagen es gab
nur minimal invasive eingriffe so ein
bisschen ein gesetzentwurf
eine million menschen arbeiten immerhin
arbeiten immer mehr die jetzt von der
steuerbefreiung des corona bonus
profitieren ist nicht minimalinvasiv
sondern gut gerecht und für die menschen
ein deutliches signal der wertschätzung
und pflegeberufen das muss noch einmal
deutlich an der stelle sagen
richtig ist die unions fraktion stimmt
heute auch zu bewährtes fortsetzen von
dem was man richtig angelegt haben
das erkennbar auch an und ich glaube das
war auch ein gutes gespräch was wir noch
hatten in der in dieser woche war es
nochmal zum abschluss dieses gesetzes
aber natürlich in der opposition
scheint man immer noch ein stück weit
mehr drauflegen zu müsste es kommt mir
ein bisschen so vorher künstler wie am
hamburger fischmarkt noch einmal hier
drauf und nochmal da also ich glaube so
funktioniert das ganze nicht ich weiß
noch ich komme einer hamburg zum
fischmarkt schauen wir das an wie das
ist aber er will ich kann mich noch
erinnern dass sie gesagt haben zum thema
der fristverlängerung der bundesrat hat
doch vorschläge macht das sei recht gut
wir sind darüber hinausgegangen was
anhören da kommen natürlich auch gelobt
da kommen noch mal eins drauf also ich
glaube müssen schauen was machbar was
notwendig ist und da haben wir auch
mitte und maß als koalition getroffen
dass sie dann mehr und machen müssen als
opposition ist vielleicht in ordnung das
müssen sie mit sich vereinbaren aber wir
machen maßnahme die gezielt sind die
insgesamt richtig sind die die richtigen
treffen und die in einem gewissen maße
mitte sind insofern sehr gutes gesetz
ich freue mich über die breite
zustimmung hier in diesem haus und würde
wer über eine wiederholung dieser großen
zustimmung bei anderen gesetzt dann auch
freuen dankeschön jetzt kommen wir zur
abstimmung über den gesetzentwurf unter
anderem zum vierten corona steuer hilfe
gesetzt hat eine kurzintervention
beantragt wie ich zu dass der kollege
stöbert das war zunächst noch die fdp
schon richtige ansatz gewachsen zunächst
wollte ich noch
verschicken das jährige aus fdp fraktion
einräumen dass die maßnahmen die ihr
vorgeschlagen werden bürger das ziel für
unsinn aber ich sage immer hans können
sie die geschichte mit dem feuerwehrmann
erfolge hermann der
massenmarkt häuser angezündet und hitler
hat als erstes und dort zu löschen genau
dass es das was ihr machen sie haben
ganze branchen ein berufsverbot und zwei
jahre lang ausgesprochen sie haben
einzelhandel gastronomie hotel zu
geschlossen obwohl das nach dem osten
noch tauen nicht mehr notwendig war
jetzt stellen sich hin und sagen wir
hätten diese branchen ist doch in
verschieden danke
aussteller von der afg war das
tun ich muss das tun was ich muss eines
klar stellt ein herz gewachsen ist mir
meine frau meine kinder nicht die afd
zum einen
zu zweit brandstifter ist ein virus und
putin und nicht wir und wir kämpfen
diese auswirkungen und das mit aller
kraft und zum wohle der menschen in der
bundesrepublik deutschland danke schön
so damit sind wir hier in der debatte
willkommen zur abstimmung
tagesordnungspunkt 10 a wir kommen zur
abstimmung über den von der
bundesregierung eingebrachten
gesetzentwurf zur umsetzung steuerlicher
hilfsmaßnahmen zur bewältigung einer
krise der finanzausschuss empfiehlt und
der buchstabe a seiner
beschlussempfehlung auf drucksache 1906
den gesetzentwurf der bundesregierung
auf drucksachen
1111 und 1646 in der ausschluss fassung
anzunehmen ich will diejenigen die den
entwurf in der ausschuss fassung
zustimmen wollen vom das handzeichen
gegenprobe
[Musik]
enthaltungen dann ist der letzte wurf in
der ausstellung in zweiter lesung bei
enthaltung der fraktionen der afg unter
linken mit den stimmen der fraktionen
des hauses angenommen nun kommt meine
lieblings abstimmung dritte beratung und
schlussabstimmung ich werde diejenigen
die dem gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen
sich zu erheben
danke schön wer stimmt dagegen
wer enthält sich
sehr schön dann ist dieser gesetzentwurf
in der dritter lesung bei den teilungen
der fraktionen der abi und der linken
mit den stimmen der fraktionen des
hauses angenommen ja mit einer kleinen
sportlichen einlage denn traditionell
ist es so dass bei der dritten lesung
hier die abgeordneten aufstehen müssen
das meint wohl der
bundestags-vizepräsident also dieses
viertel corona steuer hilfe gesetz ist
hier mit der breiten mehrheit des hauses
verabschiedet worden das hatte sich ja
in der debatte angedeutet ein ganzes
bündel steuerliche maßnahmen dass bürger
und unternehmen weiter entlasten soll
die noch mit den folgen der krise
kämpfen es ist ja viel zu den einzelnen
punkten gesagt worden das gesetz dazu
vielleicht noch mal kurz ist ja noch mal
nachgebessert worden in den
ausschussberatungen unter anderem soll
ja der korona boni für beschäftigte in
der pflege
in krankenhäusern den praxen bis zu
einem betrag von 4500 euro steuerfrei
bleiben da hatte waren zuerst eine
grenze von 3000 euro also das ist
nochmal ausgeweitet worden und auch der
kreis der anspruchsberechtigten
also tariflich und auch freiwillige
boden die steuerfrei bleiben das ist
nochmal ausgeweitet worden
zusatzpunkt 1 abstimmung über den antrag
der fraktion der afg auf druck seiner
1664 mit dem titel dem grund
steuerverfahren den erklärungsdruck
nehmen grund eigener steuerberaten.de
beruf und verwaltung entlasten wäre
stimmt für diesen antrag
klar wer stimmt dagegen enthaltungen
kleine dass dieser antrag gegen die
stimmen
gegen die stimmen der agb die stimmen
der übrigen fraktionen des hauses
abgelegt ihr wolltet ihr afd ja die
frist zur abgabe von grundsteuer
erklärungen um fünf monate verlängern
das hat ja nicht die mehrheit gefunden
so wir kommen zum nächsten thema august
2021 die bilder gingen um die welt
menschen fielen von flugzeugen
versuchten sich verzweifelt festzuhalten
zehntausende afghaninnen und afghanen
versuchten fluchtartig ihr land zu
verlassen eine teils chaotische
evakuierungsaktion nach ende des
internationalen militäreinsatzes in
afghanistan
war das im koalitionsvertrag hatten die
ampel parteien festgehalten dass das
aufgearbeitet werden soll also diese
evakuierungs mission mit einem
parlamentarischen untersuchungsausschuss
eigentlich sollte der ende märz bereits
eingesetzt werden das verzögert sich
allerdings noch heute wird hier
debattiert über einen solchen
parlamentarischen untersuchungsausschuss
auf antrag der fdp-fraktion die eben
einen entsprechenden beschluss
einbringen will einen solchen
untersuchungsausschuss
einzusetzen
[Applaus]
rené springer spricht für die afg damen
und herren liebe gäste liebe soldaten
und veteranen die vielleicht zu schauen
die alternative für deutschland hier im
deutschen bundestag beantragt hier heute
die einsetzung eines
untersuchungsausschusses zur
aufarbeitung des einsatzes in
afghanistan
der 2001 von rot-grün begonnen wurde von
vier weiteren
bundesregierungen getragen wurde und
2021 in einem desaster endete kein
einziges ziel wurde erreicht
afghanistan wurde in ein chaos gestürzt
was waren die ziele der bundesregierung
das hauptziel war die aufrechterhaltung
der sicherheit und die schaffung einer
sich selbsttragenden stabilität fakt ist
dass die anzahl der terror toten im
laufe der zeit und unter präsenz der
westlichen truppen jahr für jahr
gestiegen ist im jahr 2007 gab es
beispielsweise 2000 terror tote im jahr
8600 terror tote eine vervierfachung
2016 war der blutzoll der afghanischen
streitkräfte so groß dass die
afghanische regierung und die us
regierung beschlossen haben die zahlen
nicht mehr zu veröffentlichen und die
bundesregierung hat sich dieser
täuschung strategie angeschlossen
insgesamt sind von 2001 bis 2002 21
212.000 tote zu beklagen das ist das
ergebnis werte geleitete außenpolitik
bei der der werte export und die
demokratisierung wichtiger waren als die
realität vor ort die kulturelle
identität der afghanen und der tradition
dieser menschen wir waren in den augen
vieler afghanen keine befreiung wir
waren besatzer
ein westlicher
ein westlicher fremdkörper in eine
archaische stammeskultur und damit
selbst ein faktor für die zunehmende
instabilität in diesem land ein weiteres
ziel der bundesregierung war die
förderung von rechtsstaatlichkeit
demokratie und frauenrechte ein
wissenschaftliches gutachten das wissen
doch den dienst des bundestages sagt
jetzt einen funktionierenden rechtsstaat
hat es in afghanistan im jahr 2001 bis
2021 nie gegeben
afghanistan war spätestens seit 2010 de
facto ein gescheiterter staat die
taliban gewannen die oberhand damit auf
korruption drogen ökonomie und medizin
willkür doch die bundesregierung
verbreitete noch zehn weitere lange
jahre durchhalte parolen und gaukelte
der öffentlichkeit eine verbesserung der
lage vor die es vor ort nicht gab und
was ist mit den frauenrechten
heute ist die burka man dies in die
zeitungen wieder pflicht für frauen die
reisefreiheit von frauen ohne männliche
begleitung wird begrenzt mädchen dürfen
keine weiteren keine weiterführenden
schulen mehr besuchen das ist das
ergebnis für minister außenpolitik
die bundesregierung hat das ziel
verfolgt
drogenanbau in afghanistan zu bekämpfen
das ziel das aufgerufen wurde war die
halbierung der drogenanbau flächen
tatsächlich ist die opiumproduktion von
2001 die im letzten jahr der
taliban-herrschaft bis 2021 um das 36
fache gestiegen
36 mal mehr drogenproduktion obwohl man
den kampf gegen drogen ausgerufen hat
afghanistan ist heute der haupt drogen
produzent der haupt opium produzent
weltweit und versorgt 24 drogen von 24
millionen drogenkonsumenten 80 prozent
aller nutzer
2021 war afghanistan auch zweitgrößter
haschisch produzent der welt kein bürger
versteht wie man den kampf gegen drogen
ausrufen kann und dann entsteht dort ein
staat der sich zum global player in der
drogen ökonomie hocharbeitet kein mensch
versteht das
ein weiteres ziel der bundesregierung
war afghanischer sicherheitskräfte zu
befähigen sicherheit im eigenen land zu
gewährleisten
2003 lag die zahl der afghanischen
streitkräfte bei 6.000 2020 bei
272.000 die streitkräfte umfasst mehr
truppen und polizisten als die
bundeswehr und trotzdem konnten die
taliban nach dem abzug der westlichen
truppen truppen ohne auf nennenswerten
widerstand zu stoßen afghanistan zurück
erobern ergebnisse von 20 jahren
ausbildung ausrüstung finanzierung
training sind binnen weniger tage
pulverisiert worden wie ist so etwas
möglich
meine damen und herren dieser krieg
hatte viele verlierer aber auch gewinner
die verlierer sind die deutschen
steuerzahler die über 17 milliarden euro
bezahlt haben für diesen einsatz die
verlierer sind über 100.000 deutsche
soldaten die in diesem einsatz sinnlos
verheizt wurden die verlierer sind 59
getötete deutsche soldaten und tausende
mit einsatzbedingten psychischen
erkrankungen die heute noch damit zu
kämpfen haben und die profiteure das ist
die rüstungsindustrie die gute geschäfte
gemacht hat vor allem aber die taliban
die heute fest im sattel sitzen als noch
2001 und extrem hoch gerüstet sind durch
unsere ausstattung und durch unsere
ausbildung es ergeben sich unendlich
viele fragen aus diesem 20-jährigen
einsatz und diese fragen wollen wir im
rahmen eines untersuchungsausschuss
klären wie konnten fünf
bundesregierungen sich selbst und die
deutsche öffentlichkeit zwei jahrzehnte
lang täuschen warum setzte die
bundesregierung auf korrupte warlords
und kriegsverbrecher als partner die nur
interesse am eigenen macht ausbau hatten
aber nicht an stabilität wie konnte es
sein dass die opiumproduktion unter
westlicher präsenz stets höher lag als
unter der herrschaft der taliban
warum hat sich die bundesregierung so
lange geweigert trotz der militärisch
aussichtslosen situation mit den taliban
gespräche zu führen wie es der damalige
chef kurt beck 2007 gefordert hat und
wie es letztlich von trump dem us
präsident auch getan wurde wie viel
steuergeld ist in den händen korrupter
macht geliebten gelandet und vor allem
wie konnte eine ganze armee die größer
war als die bundeswehr innerhalb weniger
tage kollabieren diese fragen müssen aus
unserer sicht geklärt werden damit komme
ich zum schluss die aufarbeitung von 20
jahren afghanistan-einsatz wird
verwundete und traumatisierte soldaten
nicht heilen sie wird auch keinen der
getöteten drei polizisten und 59
getöteten soldaten zurückholen aber wir
sind es ihnen und ihren angehörigen
schuldig das desaster die falschen
entscheidungen die leeren versprechungen
die täuschungen die lügen schonungslos
aufzuklären
wir wollen und wir müssen die politisch
verantwortlichen zur rechenschaft ziehen
und das ist das ziel das wir mit diesem
antrag auf einsetzung eines
untersuchungsausschusses zu afghanistan
verfolgen ich bedanke mich für die
aufmerksamkeit das sagte rené springer
für die afg und das ist die grundlage
der heutigen debatte die ampel koalition
möchte ebenfalls einen parlamentarischen
untersuchungsausschuss
zu dieser in akku ihres mission in
afghanistan noch ist er nicht eingesetzt
noch gibt es die vorlage nicht jetzt
hören wir mal was ralf stegner dazu zu
sagen hat mitglied im auswärtigen
ausschuss für die spd der präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen nichts
ist gut in afghanistan so könnte man
fast wieder sagen im schatten der
ukraine krieges verschlechtert sich die
lage für die menschen täglich 95 prozent
der bevölkerung können sich nicht mehr
ausreichend ernähren besonders
dramatisch ist die situation für kinder
hinzu kommen massive gewalt gegen frauen
schwerste menschenrechtsverletzungen
geduldet oder veranlasst durch die
machthaber der taliban es ist unsere
verantwortung hier sofort und
unbürokratisch humanitäre hilfe zu
leisten
es wundert mich kein bisschen dass der
antrag daher stehe die situation der
menschen mit keinem wort erwähnt da habt
ihr geht es nie um menschen nie um
internationale zusammenarbeit und schon
gleich gar nicht um friedenssicherung
vier leitstellen bleibt der
nationalismus des vergangenen
jahrhunderts mit dieser rostigen
ideologie haben demokraten in diesem
haus in nichts gemeinsam
wir haben meine lieben kollegen eine
verantwortung dafür dass das deutsche
engagement in afghanistan aufgearbeitet
wird viele haben alle gemacht die
nationale gemeinschaft die afghanischen
regierungen noch wieder nach sage und
schreibe 20 jahren afghanistan-einsatz
der bundeswehr und deutsche
entwicklungszusammenarbeit müssen wir
daraus für zukünftige auslandseinsätze
lernen und diese mal ausrichten das ist
mit dem denken bei ihnen nicht so weit
her läuft habe ich ja schon ausgeführt
leider klappt es nicht mal mit dem lesen
hätten sie den koalitionsvertrag der spd
mit grünen und fdp gelesen wüssten sie
nämlich wir werden einen
parlamentarischen untersuchungsausschuss
sowie eine enquetekommission einsetzen
wir werden im juni
gemeinsam mit der demokratischen
opposition im untersuchungsausschuss auf
den weg bringt dafür brauchen wir hier
ein antrag nicht das ist ein bisschen
länger gedauert hat ist der klick
situation in der ukraine geschuldet was
jeder nachvollziehen kann darüber ein
bisschen urteilsvermögen verfügt das tun
sie ja bekanntermaßen nicht ihre
heldenhaften aufklärer pose bedarf es
also auch diesmal nicht und übrigens
kann ihr antrag auch nicht verdecken
dass die politische rechte kein konzept
für eine zeitgemäße europäische außen-
und sicherheitspolitik hat wenn sie
ihren fragen kann erhöhung auf denen sie
so stolzen nicht wegwerfen wollen
kleiner tipp von mir stellen sich die
fragen ein untersuchungsausschuss nehmen
wir einrichten haben werden sie
beantwortet wer wirklich etwas lernen
will verzichtet besser auf vorgezogene
schlussfolgerung auch das
disqualifiziert wurde die heutigen
debatten grundlage die ampel koalition
bekennt sich zu ihrer verantwortung die
deutsche außenpolitik an unseren werten
von frieden und freiheit der
europäischen zusammenarbeit im
prinzipien des völkerrechts auszurichten
dazu gehört immer auch eine kritische
auseinandersetzung mit den
auslandseinsätzen unser parlamentsarmee
im deutschen bundestag in seiner
zeitenwende wieder hat der bundeskanzler
angekündigt dass er mit dem
sondervermögen von 100 milliarden euro
endlich für die anständige und
zeitgemäße ausrüstung
soldatinnen und soldaten
bei der landes und bündnisverteidigung
aber auch bei den auslandseinsätzen
sorgen werden menschen dürfen niemals
beliebige figuren auf dem schachbrett
von großmacht oder ressourcen interessen
werden daher müssen auslandseinsätze an
denen die bundeswehr sich beteiligt
immer dem ziel dienen den frieden zu
sichern oder zu schaffen und humanitäre
hilfe zu leisten
außenpolitische konflikte lassen sie
haben die niemals militärisch lösen die
zeitenwende verlangt eine neuordnung
unserer außen- und sicherheitspolitik
wir werden in den nächsten monaten über
komplexe fragen von sicherheit
demokratie globaler gerechtigkeit
rüstungskontrolle einen neuen
friedensplan in dem völkerrecht
entspricht unter kommunität reden müssen
lassen sie mich im namen der ist wie die
bundestagsfraktion noch einmal unseren
soldatinnen und soldaten den zivilen
entwicklungsexperten experten und in
vielen menschen vor ort danken sie haben
im auftrag des deutschen bundestags mit
ihren partnern viele jahre dafür gesorgt
dass zeitweise sehr wohl beträchtliche
fortschritte
eingetreten sind bei der
rechtsstaatlichkeit bei den
bildungschancen für mädchen bei
frauenrechten bei infrastrukturaufbau
terrorismusbekämpfung gerade von unseren
programmen für berufliche bildung haben
viele tausend menschen profitiert die
gelernten fähigkeiten werden noch in
jahrzehnten für afghanistan von
bedeutung sein auch wenn der einsatz
nicht zu ende gegangen ist das bleibt
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
und die furchtbaren bilder vom abzug aus
afghanistan sind unser allgegenwärtig
die willkür der taliban die
unterdrückung vieler menschen vor allem
von frauen und mädchen ist unerträglich
und täglich erreichen uns auch anfragen
verzweifelter menschen die das land aus
angst um ihr leben verlassen müssen
nichts ist gut in afghanistan hat
trotzdem nur ein teil der wahrheit das
ende der afghanistan mission bedeutet im
umkehrschluss nicht dass unser einsatz
für frieden mit anderen partnern umsonst
oder falsch gewesen wäre einfache
antworten sind nie wichtig eine moderne
außen und sicherheitspolitik ist
anspruchsvoller als die schwarzweiß
debatten in social media blasen der
untersuchungsausschuss und die angeht
kommission bieten uns die gelegenheit
gemeinsam mit den demokratischen
parteien dieses hauses konstruktiv daran
zu arbeiten aus fehlern zu lernen und
unser verantworten die reden mehr als
sie denken sie sollten mal umgekehrt
halten wir werden unserer verantwortung
gerecht werden dafür dass zukünftig
besser zu machen den antrag der
rechtsradikalen leben vielen dank
gegner ob man im unterausschuss
abrüstung rüstungskontrolle und
nichtverbreitung hier mit seiner rede
auf infrage norbert röttgen mitglied im
auswärtigen ausschuss
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
zunächst ein wort zum antrag der afd
fraktion der antrag zeigt dass ihre
fraktion entweder das instrument des
untersuchungsausschusses nicht
verstanden hat oder dass dir oder dass
ihre fraktion des missbräuchlich
einsetzt im zentrum eines
untersuchungsausschusses steht die
beweisaufnahme
es geht um sachverhalt ermittlungen
allein darum geht es es geht um
sachverhalts entwicklung tatsachen
ermittlung und nicht agitation wie
können sie hier betreiben können sie
sonst nur betreiben aber dafür ist nicht
das instrument des
untersuchungsausschusses da
und insofern kann es nicht noch nicht
mal der empfehlung des kollegen stegner
anschließen dass sie ihre fragen die sie
dort formuliert haben im
untersuchungsausschuss stellen denn alle
diese fragen wären unzulässig si der
untersuchungs das sage ich bei der
untersuchungsausschüsse keinen der ganz
spezifische einzigartige funktion hat er
kann wie ein richter mit richterlichen
befugnissen beweisen kann sogar
vereidigen das heißt doch muss
vorgegangen werden wie zu gerichts
müssen die beweise gestellt werden nach
den anforderungen der
strafprozessordnung das typische an
ihren fragen ist dass sie mit ihrer
frage immer schon gleich die wertung und
bewertung vornehmen kein richter in
diesem land dürfte könnte würde solche
fragen stellen sie sind unzulässig darum
ist ein formal ihr ganzer anfang
unzulänglich und er zeigt dass es
überhaupt kein bemühen gibt sich mit
dieser dramatischen lage
auseinanderzusetzen
das möchte ich in der verbleibenden zeit
kurz tun denn ich bin davon überzeugt
dass es aus dem afghanistan-einsatz
lehren zu ziehen gibt
und wir als fraktion wie andere
fraktionen sind auch der auffassung dass
etwas aufzuarbeiten ist
und ich möchte mich auf eine lehre und
einen gegenstand der aufarbeitung hier
beziehen die nicht benennen möchte
das was mich umtreibt und ich nutze die
gelegenheit ihr zu sagen dass mich bis
dahin selten in der politik etwas so
wütend und traurig gemacht hat wie das
ergebnis des abzuges der nato-truppen
aus afghanistan
denn seitdem die nato nicht mehr in
afghanistan ist
seitdem die nato nicht mehr in
afghanistan ist ist in dieses land
terror
chaos und elend zurückgekehrt das ist
die folge des abzugs der nato die
taliban sind zurückgekehrt es herrscht
eine fürchterliche hungersnot
fürchterlich der unfähigkeit und dem
chaos des taliban-regimes geschuldet
mädchen können eben nicht mehr auf die
schule gehen frauen können kein
selbstbestimmtes leben mehr führen die
scharia wird angewendet in dem chaos
dieses landes
das ist das ergebnis
der entscheidung dass die nato abgezogen
ist als die nato da war war eine zeit
von freiheit und selbstbestimmung und
stabilität in afghanistan seit langen
und jahrzehnten nicht mehr erlebt hatte
das war die realität
und wir müssen uns doch mit damit
beschäftigen wie wir diesen lieber den
genau ist das ist wieder die gewohnte
übereinstimmung von afg und
linksfraktion in der außenpolitik
absolute übereinstimmung sie sind der
meinung die nato ist schuld ich bin der
meinung das problem ist dass die nato
nicht mehr da ist und das ist ja
empirisch bewiesen weil vorher weil
vorher in einem ausmaß stabilität und
freiheit und selbstbestimmung
möglichkeit war und jetzt haben wir es
wieder zurück also müssen wir doch
fragen was ist falsch gelaufen
wie konnte es dazu kommen
sie meinen es war weil die nato da war
ich sage es ist weil die nato nicht mehr
dabei warum ist die nato nicht mehr da
die nato ist nicht mehr da weil
präsident tom so entschieden hat america
first das ist nicht mehr unser interesse
und er hat mit den taliban verhandelt
und selbst diese verhandlungen ob
studiert dadurch dass er einfach einen
abzugstermin genannt hat die taliban
mussten nicht mal verhandeln sie muss
nur abwarten
dann kam der amtswechsel präsident biden
und er hat im wesentlichen mit einer
vier monatigen verzögerung diese politik
dieses desaströse desaströse erbe nur
fortsetzen können und die amerikaner
sind abgezogen die europäer wussten das
ist falsch der europäer wussten es ist
falsch aber wir wussten auch wir sind
nicht in der lage
unsere interessen zu vertreten das
außenpolitisch zu tun was wir für
richtig halten weil wir die
möglichkeiten die militärischen
möglichkeiten dazu nicht haben das ist
die lehre und die erfahrung wenn sie mal
ihr dummes gerede für eine halbe minute
einstellen könnten wäre ich ihnen
dankbar sie haben außerdem
zwei zu tragen und es rührt mich auch
deshalb weil ich hier nur das elend von
menschen rede und sie haben nichts
anderes im sinn als ihre dummen
parteipolitischen sprüche zu einer
beleidigung zu erhöhen
ihre auffassung dass wie früher schon
gesagt dass das zwischenrufen nicht die
der geschäftsordnung deutschen
bundestages entspricht noch nicht
wirklich sonderlich intelligent ist wenn
sie was zu sagen war dann melden sie
sich ich lasse den posten der national
gerne zu wenn sie das wollen aber den
redner durch dauerndes zwischenrufen zu
stören ist einfach stillos
und damit bin ich bei der lehre wir
müssen uns
mit der europäischen machen beschäftigen
die wir erlebt haben der amerikanische
rückzug hat am ritz europäische ohnmacht
sichtbar gemacht für die amerikaner ist
das ein ozean weit entfernt diese region
wird auch nicht mehr priorität der
interessen der amerikaner werden aber es
ist aufs engste und untrennbar mit der
sicherheit und stabilität in europa
verbunden wie es in der region in
zentralasien und nord und im nahen und
mittleren osten aussieht das ist die
lehre die wir ziehen müssen um unserer
sicherheit willen und auch unserer
verantwortung für die menschen dort wir
dürfen wegen unserer eigenen interessen
und wegen unserer verantwortung
europäische ohnmacht nicht weiter dulden
wir müssen entschieden und selber
befähigen unsere eigenen interessen zu
vertreten meine damen und herren um das
zweite ist das ist die art und weise des
rückzugs unsere ohnmacht hat sich bis in
die art und weise des rückzugs ja am
ende fast der fluchtartigen des
fluchtartigen abzugs aus afghanistan
gezeigt ich selber bin angerufen wurden
von eltern und schulleitungen von
kindern und schülern die in afghanistan
waren deutsche schüler afghanischer
abstammung die zu denen es kein kontakt
ab wir haben menschen zurückgelassen die
mit denen die abo operiert haben und das
muss aufgeklärt werden warum waren wir
auf den schlechten verlauf der dinge
nicht vorbereitet wer hat wie ag wie
lief die koordination so etwas darf
nicht mehr passieren und bevor wir zu
den wertungen kommen müssen wir den
sachverhalten und die tatsachen
ermitteln seriöse das ist unsere
verantwortung wir wollen dieser
verantwortung gerecht werden die cdu csu
fraktion ist in guten gesprächen mit den
koalitionsfraktionen
um den sachverhalt zu ermitteln um zu
ermitteln was ist falsch gelaufen es ist
unsere verantwortung lehren und
konsequenzen zu ziehen das ist das gebot
der stunde dem wollen wir folgen vielen
dank
norbert röttgen macht hier auf die lage
in afghanistan aufmerksam auch die
bundeskanzlerin die ehemalige hat ja
dort schon fehleinschätzung der lage in
dem land eingeräumt und so auch der
außenminister zu der zeit heiko maas an
joschka broker spricht jetzt für die
grünen-fraktion und kollegen sehr
geehrter herr präsident mit ihrer
erlaubnis zitiere ich wir sind dann erst
mal nur per telefon zu erreichen wir
zerstören die alte schönen sonntag noch
ende
das sind die letzten worte die im august
2021 aus der deutschen botschaft ans
auswärtige amt gekabelt wurden danach
machte sich der stellvertretende
botschafter mit seinen verbliebenen
mitarbeiter innen auf den weg zum
flughafen es waren dramatische stunden
in karben das von den taliban überrannt
wurde es war auch das brutale ende eines
sehr langen und schwierigen
bundeswehreinsatzes lassen sie mich
vorweg schicken als abgeordnete die die
einsätze der bundeswehr in afghanistan
immer sehr kritisch gesehen hat möchte
ich zunächst allen soldatinnen
diplomatischen und zivilen helferinnen
und all den menschen in afghanistan
danke die über jahre alles gegeben haben
um das leben der menschen dort zu
verbessern und ihnen den dramatischen
stunden des abzuges alles getan haben um
so viele menschen wie möglich zu retten
und wird im schadenfall überheblichen
und pseudo belehrenden ton den die wir
hier von rechts gehört haben den findig
abschluss absolut deplatziert in dieser
wichtigen debatte
ich meinte die rede des kollegen der
eingefangen hat ja es gab sehr viel
meine damen und herren auch dass wir
kritisch zurück blicken mussten zu einem
auf das deutsche und internationale
engagement der letzten 20 jahre und zum
anderen auf den chaotischen abzug und
die frage warum eine evakuierung von
staatsbürgern von personal von orts
kräften und besonders gefährdeten
gruppen nicht viel sorgfältiger
vorbereitet wurde warum menschen die
unser engagement in afghanistan
unterstützt haben ausharren mussten
obwohl sie schon vor jahren anträge
gestellt haben weil sie bedroht waren
das bleibt diesen menschen zu helfen
nach wie vor eine sehr wichtige aufgabe
im koalitionsvertrag haben wir
vereinbart und mit der genehmigung des
präsidenten zitiere ich wir wollen die
evakuierungs mission des afghanistan
einsatzes in einem parlamentarischen
untersuchungsausschuss aufarbeiten zudem
wollen wir den gesamteinsatz in einer in
kat kommission mit wissenschaftlicher
expertise evaluieren die gewonnenen
erkenntnisse müssen praxisnah und
zukunftsgerichtet aufgearbeitet werden
so dass sie in die gestaltung
zukünftiger deutsche auslandseinsätze
einfließen und es ist nicht gewöhnlich
dass sie einen untersuchungsausschuss im
koalitionsvertrag von
regierungsfraktionen finden aber weil
diese fragen so ernst weiter abzug so
dramatisch war haben sich hier
fraktionen demokratische fraktion aus
opposition und koalition zusammen getan
um eine ernsthafte debatte hinzubekommen
und ich kann ihnen versichern wir sind
gemeinsam in sehr guten gesprächen ohne
den brutalen angriffs krieg in der
ukraine wären wir schon so weit aber ich
bin gerade mit blick auf die letzten
drei monate sehr dankbar wie sachlich
konstruktiv wir in der ampel und auch
gemeinsam mit der union zusammenarbeiten
konnten das ist für mich auch gerade in
die ernsten zeiten ausdruck eines neuen
politikstils jenseits dieser virtuellen
rollen die wir glaube ich alle satt
haben von regierung und opposition und
er sollte schule machen
die einzigen die versuchen aus dieser